Telekolle, Englisch, Folge 2342. Wörter mit Technikbezug. Wir beginnen wie immer mit den Hausaufgaben aus der letzten Folge. In diesem Fall mit der Aussprache für das Wort die Sequenz im Englischen. Sehr gut. Lernen wir nun ein neues Wort. Es ist die Abkürzung für iPhone OS. Kurz iOS. Listen and repeat. Hören Sie nun die gelernten Wörter in einer typischen Unterhaltung.
Jetzt gibt es seit einem Monat oder ein bisschen länger gibt es den zweiten Teil, die Sequenz 2.
Für iOS. Und jetzt die Continuation.
Genau, es gibt mehrere Tests. Also wir haben auch normales Gen, einfach auf die Kamera zu gehen. Das ist noch was anderes. Der Grund, warum wir Gen auf der Stelle genommen haben, das wird jetzt wieder ein bisschen science-y, zum einen kannst du halt beliebig lange die Patienten gehen lassen, zum anderen wird ein anderes kognitives Programm abgestibilt beim Gen auf der Stelle. Also du hast normalerweise beim Vorwärts-Gen so einen Automatismus in deinem Kopf, der für dich das großen Teil des Denken übernimmt. Und du musst halt kognitiv gegenarbeiten, um nicht ganz normal nach vorne zu laufen, wenn du auf der Stelle gehst. So und das interessante ist, dass man halt bei dem Test dann zum Beispiel sowas wie Fatigue, also Ermüdbarkeit analysieren kannst. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt einfach sechs Minuten auf der Stelle gehst, ist klar, dass du irgendwann keinen Bock mehr hast und quasi versuchst, so viel Energie zu minimieren und weniger Umfang hast und vielleicht ein bisschen langsamer wirst. Aber wenn du jetzt eine Patientengruppe wie zum Beispiel Multiple Sclerose-Patienten hast, bei denen ist das halt pathologisch. Das heißt, die werden deutlich schneller und deutlich schwerer ermüdbar. Und das kannst du halt bei diesem Test dann zum Beispiel schauen. Und du kannst einen, also ein Aspekt, den du testen kannst, zweiter Aspekt sind Asymetrien. Sowohl Arme-Armbewegung und Beinbewegung. Wie ist das so im Verhältnis? Als auch, wie sind einfach nur die Arme und nur die Beine gegeneinander. Und das dritte, mit am spannendste ist, es gibt bei Parkinson-Patienten ein Symptom, das nennt sich Freezing of Gate. Heißt, die Patienten laufen oder gehen oder versuchen zu gehen, fangen an zu tippeln und freezen. Also die können sich nicht mehr weiter bewegen. Die sind wirklich so wie in Schockstarre. Es ist noch nicht klar, woher das kommt, aber es gibt so ein paar Theorien. Die kommen halt teilweise auch alleine dort nicht mehr raus. Das heißt, Ärzte müssen sie dann schubsen. Damit die dann wirklich, weil diese Auffangbewegung ist dann wieder ein Automatismus und dann können sie wieder weiterlaufen. Oder es gibt halt so Audio-Cueing, das halt einen Takt vorgegeben wird. Dann müssen sie in dem Takt laufen. Dann ist halt auch dieser automatierte Mechanismus im Kopf, der ist halt irgendwie kaputt. Ganz unwissenschaftlich ausgedrückt. Das heißt, man muss irgendwie diesen Automatismus unterbrechen, damit es dann plötzlich wieder weitergeht. Und das Interessante ist, dass das auch beim Gehen auf der Stelle passiert. Das haben wir bei bestimmten Parkinson-Patienten beobachtet. Und das ist noch nicht gut erforscht. Und das ist auch in der Forschung sehr schwierig zu triggern. Weil wenn ein Patient aufgeregt ist, passiert sowas nicht unbedingt. Also wenn der normale Arzt ihn anguckt, einmal im Quartal oder alle halbe Jahr, dann kann der Patient das teilweise berichten. Aber das tritt dann halt nicht unbedingt auf. Und das ist dann nur Patient muss sagen, ob es auftritt oder nicht. Oder nur Angehöriger muss sagen. Und das ist halt sehr schwierig. Und deshalb finden wir den Test halt so spannend auf der Stelle zu gehen.
Was ist dann eigentlich so, wenn du mal, also das System soll ja möglichst irgendwann auch beim Patienten eingesetzt werden.
Ja.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn das, ich sag mal, dem Parken so einen Patienten passiert ist, während er alleine den Test macht?
Dann, normalerweise bleiben die dann, also das ist ja was bei denen auch im Alltag passiert.
Also das kennen die, das ist im Alltag.
Das ist halt ein Symptom, was die oft beschreiben, aber was halt nicht so richtig gut klinisch beobachtet werden kann. Weil, ja, es ist halt schwierig zu triggern und dann gibt es halt auch diese Diskussionen.
Aber können die sich dann alleine irgendwie rausmanövrieren?
Ja, im Normalfall. Also es dauert halt dann. Bei ganz schwer Betroffenen, die bleiben dann halt wirklich mehrere Minuten lang stehen und müssen dann sich selbst irgendwie versuchen, eine Q zu geben, um wieder neu, also es gibt dann halt zum Beispiel unterschiedliche Strategien. Zählen hilft oder einen großen Schritt machen, um zu versuchen, dann wieder weiterzukommen. Da haben manche, also unterschiedliche Patienten einfach unterschiedliche Strategien. Und da gibt es halt auch tatsächlich Entwicklungen, damit das Ganze so ein bisschen Tooling-mäßig unterstützt wird. Also es gibt AR-Anwendungen, die halt genau das analysieren, welche AR-Qs würden helfen, um diese Patienten aus dem Freezing wieder rauszuholen.
Du hast ja gesagt, ihr macht das mit der Kinect. Das heißt, ihr erfasst quasi von einer Position her, ist das dann schon dreidimensional oder ist es eher zweidimensional? Ich würde ja mal vermuten, es ist genauso interessant, jetzt mit jemandem bei diesem gehen, sowohl von vorne als auch von der Seite so zu schauen und dann diese beiden Bewegungsmuster zusammen zu kriegen.
Ja, im Prinzip kriegen wir dreidimensionale Daten, aber nicht von einer kompletten 3D-Ansicht vom Patienten. Dazu brauchen wir mehrere Kinects, was auch geht, aber meistens gar nicht notwendig ist.
Also wenn man jetzt so, was weiß ich, die Knie irgendwie über X oder so eng zueinander oder breitbeinig läuft, ist das ja auch eine Information.
Genau, also das kriegst du aber im normalen Fall.
Das reicht so, wenn man von der Seite macht.
Nee, du hast die Kamera vor dir und die nimmt ja Tiefeninformationen auf, zusätzlich zu XY-Koordinaten. Also du kriegst Informationen quasi über einen 3D-Punkt im Raum.
Ja, schon klar. Aber reicht es, wenn man das von vorne macht?
Es kommt darauf an, was du machen willst. Also ich sage nicht zu allem Ja. Genau, das ist ja im Prinzip unsere Forschung. Was geht und wie genau geht es und wie genau muss es sein, um klinisch? Also zum Beispiel, was sehr, sehr grenzwertig ist, sind Tremor-Analysen von der Hand. Also so Zittern. Sehr leichtes Zittern, sehr hochfrequentes Zittern. Der Sensor hat halt nur irgendwie 30 Hertz. Das heißt, im Prinzip kannst du schon alles, was schneller als 13 Hertz ist, nicht mehr messen. Und wenn du dazu noch eine kleine Bewegungsamplitude hast, das geht halt nicht. Oder das geht nur in ganz bestimmten Szenarien. Dann musst du halt sehr nah ran an den Sensor. Und also das ist so, es geht sehr, sehr viel. Und man muss halt dann den richtigen Trade-off zwischen noch genau genug und ja, sinnvoll im weitesten Sinne finden. Also gibt es ganz viele unterschiedliche Forschungsansätze und Bereiche. Manche nutzen nur die 3D-Daten. Manche nutzen halt schon diese Skelett-Daten, die automatisch extrahiert werden. Und im Prinzip für jeden Task oder für jede Fragestellung brauchst du einen neuen Ansatz. Wir haben zum Beispiel auch eine große Schlafstudie gemacht, wo wir einfach eine Kinect quasi übers Bett gestellt haben. Und dann wurden halt automatisch Bein-Signale, also periodic leg movement heißt das, Symptom. Da haben Patienten halt wirklich immer wieder, dass das Bein quasi zuckt. Und die können dann halt dadurch nicht schlafen, weil einfach das Bein sich quasi die ganze Zeit bewegt. Und du musst halt ins Schlaflabor, um das diagnostiziert zu bekommen. Und das ist schwierig. Andere Sache ist halt Atemaussetzer beim Schlafen. Also Patient schnarcht und irgendwann kriegt er gar keine Luft mehr. Hat Atemaussetzer, nennt sich Apnoe. Genau. Und dann setzt es halt wieder ein. Und wir haben im Prinzip nur eine Pilotstudie gemacht mit 80 Leuten. Ist das so, wie schwer schlimm ist? Es ist schon schlimm. Also es kann pathologisch werden. Pathologisch heißt, es kann schlimm werden. Normale Atemaussetzer, wenn das halt nur kurz ist, kann mal passieren. Aber wenn das mehrmals die Nacht ist und über, ich glaube drei Sekunden ist der Threshold oder so, dann ist das halt jedes Mal für den Körper Stress. Weil im Prinzip macht er erst wieder diese Atembewegung, wenn der Körper mit Sauerstoff unterversorgt ist und quasi Erstickung droht. Dann kommt halt dieses Signal, ich ersticke gerade, atme mal. Und deshalb holen die dann auch tief Luft. Also, ja, alte Menschen mit Übergewicht haben leider höheres Risiko 4 ab 0. Du hast so besorgt geguckt.
Naja, man weiß ja nicht, was man nachts so macht, ne?
Ja, aber ich denke, das kann das iPhone oder deine Uhr messen, was du so hast.
Meine Uhr hab ich ja nicht an nachts.
Die muss ja geladen werden, haha.
Also sie müsste nicht unbedingt geladen werden, weil die hält jetzt auch mal zwei Tage durch.
Aber die Frage ist ja auch dann, was sie macht. Also ob sie das aufnehmen würde, wenn du den Atemaussetzer hast. Ob man das aufnehmen kann, wenn sie am Handgelenk ist.
Atmen ist noch mal was anderes, das ist ja nicht brütlich.
Also in der Klinik wird das halt gemessen mit einmal so einem Brustgurt, genau. Aber auch mit Sonden einer Nase und am Kielkopf, weil je nachdem, wo quasi der Atemaussetzer stattfindet, ich frag dir mit im Chat, ob jemanden dauerhafte Schäden verursacht. Naja, wenn dein Gehirn die Nacht 20, 40, 60 Mal immer mal wieder kurz mit Sauerstoff unterversorgt ist, kann das.
Anders ist auch die Dummheit vieler Leute nicht zu erklären.
Das war jetzt irgendwie unverhofft, was hier um dir gekommen von, Dennis. Welche hast du denn da im Sinn?
Also kann klinisch sein und kann halt. Also ich habe ich habe tatsächlich Patientenaufnahmen gesehen, die im Prinzip die ganze Nacht durchweg regelmäßig alle ein, zwei Minuten für fünf, sechs, teilweise zehn Sekunden lang nicht geatmet haben und da fragst du dich dann schon, geht es denen noch, also geht es denen gut im Sinne von.
Naja, aber über die Zeit hinweg. Also sag mal, du schläfst.
Ja, aber danach kommt auch gleich so ein Schnappatmer, oder?
Aber du hast ja trotzdem die Unterversorgung. Du machst ja eine Unterversorgung.
Nein, dein Gehirn stirbt nicht komplett ab, aber dein Körper reagiert schon drauf. Also das ist ja genau dieser Weckruf, von wegen irgendwas funktioniert gerade nicht richtig und es kommt nicht genug Sauerstoff an. Und hier bitte einmal Notwahl.
Ich hätte gedacht, dass es ein bisschen länger sein muss, um schlimm zu werden als zehn Sekunden.
Ich kann auch mal nachgucken. Ich hatte teilweise Patienten, wo es im Minutenbereich lag. Aber das war halt nicht 20-30 Mal die Nacht, aber das war schon nicht schön für die Patienten.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, an welchem Zeitpunkt, das weißt du wahrscheinlich auch nicht aus dem Kopf, wann die Unterversorgung des Gehirns wirklich zu bleibenden Schäden führen kann.
Ich hab mal was gehört von richtig dauerhaft ernsthaft wird es bei drei Minuten, aber auch kleinere Dauern können halt. Vor allem, das ist ja dann nicht nur der reine Sauerstoff-Unterversorgung, sondern das ist ja dann auch zum Beispiel Adrenin und Herzfrequenz steigt an. Und das ist einfach eine dauerhafte Belastung für dieses komplette Herz-Kreislauf-System. Also das ist aus mehreren Gründen nicht cool.
Ja, aus der Abteilung, wie wir werden alle sterben und wie wir das vielleicht mit dem Durch den Einsatz moderner Gadgets noch verhindern oder das Misser herauszögern können. Hatten wir in den letzten beiden Sendungen hier schon viel Debatte, weil ja diese neue Apple Watch rausgebracht hat mit der EKG-Funktion. Hast du das irgendwie mitbekommen?
Die Lady hat mir gesagt, du guck mal hier, Apple Watch, EKG, what the fuck.
Das hast du vergessen.
Ich hab dann mal kurz geguckt, aber das war jetzt nicht, also ja, Apple Watch selbst hat das jetzt irgendwie neu, aber es gab ja vorher schon FDA-Approval-Software, die im Prinzip EKG gemacht hat. Also das ist jetzt zwar integriert, ging aber irgendwie vorher schon, also ich hab...
Aber nicht auf der Apple Watch.
Na doch, mit der Apple Watch. Also das ist Software, die FDA-approved ist, ich glaube 2000.
Ja, aber wie soll die denn das messen?
Ohne den Sensor.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Nee, nee, ich glaube, hast du mir nicht einen Link geschickt, dass das eine andere Uhr war?
Ach, das war nur eine Uhr.
Das war ein anderes Gerät.
Das war ein mobiles EKG-Gerät.
Nee, nee, nee, es war eine Uhr. Es war eine Uhr.
Es war eine Uhr, oder ein kleines Beweis. Die halt im Prinzip die zwei Kunden arbeiten.
Das ist nicht.
Ich glaube, es gab noch sowas, was mit Bluetooth quasi mit der Apple Watch nochmal separat und dann sind auch immer das.
Also im Prinzip, da ist das so ein kleines bisschen, ihr müsst euch ein bisschen bewusst sein, man kann reine Software als Medizinprodukt zertifizieren.
Ja, und meiner, meinem Verständnis nach ist das jetzt auch bei der Apple Watch so.
Genau.
Also es ist quasi die App auf der Uhr, die zwar den Sensor der Uhr benutzt, aber es ist quasi die App, die zertifiziert ist.
Genau, genau. Das heißt, die Apple Watch selbst ist kein Medizinprodukt. Und das, was ich halt gelesen hab, das war, wo auch so ein bisschen Unverständnis war, die Software ist nicht für herzkranke Patienten zugelassen, sondern nur für Gesunde. Das heißt, also oder ja, das ist so ein bisschen das.
Also für welche, die sich für gesund halten.
Genau, genau.
Das heißt, Gesunde dürfen das EKG benutzen und wenn das EKG sagt, du bist aber jetzt krank, dann darfst du es nicht mehr benutzen.
Dann musst du zum Arzt gehen. Ja, aber zum Beispiel, wenn du schon eine Herzerkrankung hast, dann ist das nicht genau genug. Dann kann auch teilweise die Algorithmen nicht richtig funktionieren und komplett falsche Messwerte im Prinzip.
Ich würde gerade sagen, dann brauchen sie ja deine, um zu sagen, was jetzt ein neuer, signifikanter Unterschied zu deinen vorherigen Messwerten, müssten sie ja diese Basiskurve von dir sozusagen haben, um das auf den Algorithmus anpassen zu können, oder?
Das ist ja dann noch ein Schritt weiter, es geht ja gar nicht darum zu erkennen, was krank ist oder was falsch ist, sondern wenn du ein Medizinprodukt zulässt, musst du halt ganz genau eingrenzen, für wen ist dieses Produkt zugelassen. Und im Prinzip, wenn du nicht belegen kannst, dass es für eine Risikogruppe funktioniert, müsstest du eine Studie mit dieser Risikogruppe machen, um zu zeigen, das ist safe, das funktioniert, es entsteht kein Schaden an Patienten, es kommen hier nicht irgendwie falsche Messwerte raus und das ist halt eine große Hürde und das ist halt echt schwierig für viele zu realisieren.
Das können die aber nachliefern eigentlich, oder? Weil die werden wahrscheinlich die meisten EKG-Daten weltweit haben, wenn sie irgendwie wie viele Millionen Uhren verkaufen die inzwischen.
Brauchen wir nicht genau, aber es ist schon ein Millionen Bereich.
Ist schon ziemlich viel. Niemand hat dann so viele EKG-Daten wie Apple, kann man mal annehmen, wenn sie die einkassieren. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie sie die sammeln.
Sie haben ja auch eine Kooperation, also ich hab mal vor einiger Zeit mit jemandem geredet, der in dem Medizin-Kram unterwegs war und der unter anderem diese Verwaltung, es hört sich jetzt ein bisschen falsch an, aber die Verwaltung der Apple-Daten, um sie dann weiterzugeben, an die Krankenhäuser für die Forschung. Also gibt es ja einige Kooperationen halt auch hier in Deutschland, dass sie die Apple Watch-Daten nutzen dürfen, um damit weiter Forschung zu betreiben.
Genau, was ich jetzt nicht weiß, ist, also man kann jetzt die Apple Watch in Deutschland kaufen. Die App, die ich gesehen hatte, das war nur FDA-Approval.
Die gibt's halt nicht.
Genau, also die sind dann in generell Europa nicht zugelassen, diese Apps. Und die dürfen auch nicht als Medizinprodukt vertrieben werden.
Das heißt, sie könnten die App natürlich trotzdem installieren, dürfen dann aber nicht groß damit werben und das werden sie nicht tun. Deswegen vermute ich mal, werden sie sich bemühen, hier in Europa, wie heißt noch mal gleich die Medizinbehörde, EMDR?
Ne, es gibt keine direkte Behörde. MDD oder MDR?
Die europäische, da hatten wir letztes Mal EMDR oder wie war das? Ach Gottchen, europäische Medizin, was war denn das? EMAA und dann haben sie sich, glaube ich, irgendwie umbenannt, ich hab's leider nicht. Die europäische Arzneimittelagentur.
Die Funktion auf europäischen Uhren disabled, oder?
Ist eine Agentur der Europäischen Union, die für die Beurteilung und Überwachung von Arzneimitteln zuständig ist. Aber nicht nur, sondern eben auch für die anderen Bereiche, soweit ich das verstanden habe.
Aber die machen nicht das Approval. Also das System in Europa ist so ein kleines bisschen anders und weniger überschaubar.
Liefer mir doch mal deinen Blick da drauf. Das wussten wir halt auch letztes Mal schon nicht und haben halt nur dummes Zeug geredet.
Genau, also im Prinzip bist du in Europa ein Medizinprodukt, wenn du dich nach ISO 13485 und ein paar anderen ISOs zertifizieren lässt. Und im Prinzip gibt es halt internationale, vereinheitlichte Vorgaben und Formen. Das ist so ein ganzer Verbund, nach dem du dich zertifizieren lassen musst. Das heißt, als Unternehmen oder als Produkt? Beides. Also du kannst dich als Unternehmen, als 13485, dann stellst du quasi sicher, dass du nach diesen Vorgaben entwickelst, Produkte oder Software entwickelst. Das Produkt selbst muss aber auch noch mal zertifiziert werden, wenn es ein Medizinprodukt ist. Und dann gibt es halt unterschiedliche Klassen von Medizinprodukten, von 1 bis 3. Das Durchschnittliche ist so 1, 2a, 2b, 3. 3 ist halt wirklich hochinvasiv, Implantate, Herzschrittmacher oder teilweise Röntgens Software ist jetzt ganz neu, Klasse 3. Also das, was dich wirklich entweder chronisch schädigen oder töten kann, ist Klasse 3 Medizinprodukt.
Klasse 3 von ISO 13485?
Und im Prinzip gibt es halt diese großen internationalen Normen, die werden dann in verschiedenen Schritten national übersetzt. Und dann gibt es nochmal nationale Regeln und also MPG, Medizinproduktgesetz, was halt dann auf die Normen verweist und alles sehr, sehr groß und sehr, sehr unübersichtlich. Und es wird gerade komplett umgestellt. Also es gibt halt neue Verordnungen. Anstatt die MED gibt es jetzt, glaube ich, die MDR oder andersrum. Nee, MDR ist, glaube ich, die neue. Wo dann auch zum Beispiel Software besser geregelt ist. Also derzeit ist Software zu neu gewesen, in Anführungszeichen, dass man es sehr, sehr schwierig abbilden konnte unter den jetzigen Regulatorien. Ist kein Medizinprodukt. Hat keine medizinische Diagnostik, keine Zweckbestimmung.
Das ist nur die Ursache deines Problems.
Genau. Aber genau das wurde halt so ein bisschen angegangen, weil früher Software, die halt im Krankenhaus eingesetzt wurde und so Medikamentenverordnungen gemacht hat oder dieses komplette Krankenhaus-Informationssystem, was im Prinzip alle Daten verwaltet hat, war vorher kein Medizinprodukt. Das heißt, es ist wahrscheinlich in irgendeiner Weise hoffentlich zertifiziert, aber halt nicht, du musst es nicht belegen, dass wenn du hier Medikament 1.1 eingibst, dort auch Medikament 1 steht und nicht plötzlich Medikament 2 oder einer anderen Dosierung oder sonst was. Aber ja, jedenfalls in Deutschland gibt es verschiedene benannte Stellen, Notified Buddies und im Prinzip suchst du dir halt einen so einen Buddy und der zertifiziert dich nach den Richtlinien. Der sagt dann, du machst alles richtig und du hast dein Qualitätsmanagementsystem, du hast deine Risikobewertung, du hast Usability getestet, deine Software funktioniert soweit, wie ich sehe. Und dann gibt es verschiedene Instanzen, wo du halt dann sagen musst, ja hier ist ein Problem mit aufgetreten und hier ich muss jetzt einen Rückruf machen und du musst dich auf 30 gefühlt unterschiedlichen Plattformen anmelden. Also es ist in Europa deutlich weniger übersichtlich, als einfach zur FDA zu gehen und hier. Die FDA hat schöne Guidelines, zum Beispiel auch Software als Medizin-Produkt-Guidelines, wo du dich dann halt im Prinzip an die halten kannst.
Ist nicht unmöglich.
Jetzt muss ich direkt mal kurz nachfragen. Welche Klasse werdet ihr sein?
Wir werden ein Messgerät sein.
Also eine Klasse 6.
1M.
Achso, Klasse 1, nämlich auch Gehelfen und Rollstuhl.
Weil ihr bringt ja keinen um und so weiter.
Nein, wir bringen keinen um.
Wo schlägst du das gerade nach, Letty?
In der Wikipedia gibt es bei Medizin-Produkt Beispiele für konkrete Medizin-Produkte in den Klassen.
In den Chat.
Du hast ja das Medizin-Produkt da schon.
Sag mal, so ein Medizin-Produkt, haben die auch so eine Art TÜV? Also sagen wir mal jetzt hier, bei der Charité steht bestimmt auch so ein riesen Röntgen-Gerät von Siemens rum oder so angenommen. Siemens würde sich jetzt auflösen und würde nicht mehr existieren. Dürften die dann für immer und ewig weiter das Röntgen-Gerät benutzen? Oder müssen die das dann einstellen, weil es keine mehr testen, überprüfen, warten und so weiter kann? Oder ist einmal zugelassen und dann ist zugelassen?
Nee, im Prinzip, wenn es halt die Firma nicht mehr gibt, müssen eigentlich alle zurückgerufen werden. Alle?
Theoretisch oder ist das?
Lass mich raten, es gibt tausende Geräte, die nicht zurückgerufen werden.
Das Problem ist, dass das halt wer soll das überprüfen. Und von wegen TÜV, die kriegen halt einen CE-Kennzeichen. Also auch als Software, wenn du eine zertifizierte Software bist, hast du dann dein CE-Kennzeichen.
Verstehe.
Das ist so was ähnliches wie ein TÜV-Siegel.
Das könnt ihr dann hinten auf eure Packungsbeilage drucken.
Wir können das in die Software integrieren als kleines JPEG, von wegen hier total verpixelt. Das ist unser CE-Siegel. Müssen wir sogar. Wir müssen das kennzeichnen als Medizinprodukt.
Das heißt, in der Software quasi in dem Bauteil zum Beispiel?
Genau. Da steht dann ein kleines CE-Siegel. Das ist noch...
Das heißt, ihr habt die Kinect zertifiziert?
Nein, das haben wir eben nicht. Wir sind, wir, das wäre nur eine reine Software-Zertifizierung. Da gibt es auch so ein bisschen... Genau, da gibt es halt so ein bisschen Hin und Her. Die einen sagen halt, dass die Kinect ein sogenanntes Accessory ist. Und alles, was essentiell wichtig ist für die Durchführung der Messung, müsste eigentlich auch medizinprodukt zertifiziert sein. Aber dann müsstest du auch Laptops, auf denen die Software läuft, z.B. zertifizieren. Andere Sache ist halt, du kannst einfach nur, oder das, was halt eigentlich standardmäßig gemacht wird, du definierst genau, was müssen die Devices können, welche Auflösung, welche Frame Rate, welche Devices sind kompatibel. So ist es halt dann z.B. auch mit der Apple Watch. Und du musst jedes neue Update von diesem Device, jedes neue Update von der Software validieren, ob das noch deinen Ansprechen entspricht. Und wenn es das tut, ist alles in Ordnung. Wenn es das nicht tut, hast du ein Problem.
Richtig so.
Ja, an sich ja, auf jeden Fall. Gehst dann halt so kleinschrittig. Du musst eigentlich auch jede Software, die du für die Entwicklung einsetzt, validieren. Und wenn du halt dann z.B. einen Web-Tool hast, was einfach täglich eine neue Version einspielt, rein theoretisch, wenn du genau sein willst, musst du jede einzelne Version, bevor du sie einsetzen darfst, überprüfen, ob sich etwas sicherheitsrelevantes, irgendwie funktionskritisches geändert hat. Und dann musst du das validieren und dokumentieren und einreichen. Und das macht dann schon weniger Spaß.
Wir haben da auch gerade drüber gequatscht, was das halt auch heißt für die Erweiterung der Software. Also wenn so UI-Elemente zum Beispiel einfach nur hinzugefügt werden müssen, dass halt die Firma von Tala schon vorher irgendwie spezifizieren müsste, was genau sie braucht, bevor überhaupt die eigentliche Entwicklung stattfindet. Und vor allem sowas wie, da kann ich mich nicht mehr genau dran erinnern, also wenn man zum Beispiel so sagt, hey wir wollen jetzt hier eine Visualisierung drin haben und weil wir nicht die Standard XY-Visualisierung haben wollen, sondern zusammen mit den, er macht einen ganz irre, wenn ihr euch hier so angrenzt, Entschuldigung, sondern mit den Ärzten vielleicht zusammen hingehen will und sagt, hey wir wollen mal mit euch darüber reden, wie ihr die Software überhaupt benutzt und ist sage ich mal dieses Balkendiagramm hier überhaupt das, was ihr braucht oder wie sieht denn euer Arbeitsflow so generell aus? Also du müsstest eigentlich auch, bevor du diesen Prozess anstoßen kannst, um herauszufinden, was genau die Anforderungen an die neue UI oder was auch immer sind, müsstet Tala eigentlich schon längst spezifiziert haben, was genau die Anforderungen sind, wie sie aussehen müssen. Also was halt so ein bisschen an einigen Stellen natürlich auch so schwierig wird.
Ja, also das ist halt generell so, diese kompletten Herangehensweisen und Dokumentationspflicht ist alles weniger agil, also nicht unbedingt freundlich für agile Softwareentwicklung, sondern ist halt sehr, du musst halt erst die Risikoanalyse machen oder du musst erst im Prinzip dein Lastenheft haben oder deine User-Requirements, bevor du überhaupt irgendwas, du musst vorher festlegen, welche Tools du benutzen willst, weil die validiert werden müssen, bevor du erst einen, also es ist halt so noch eine sehr v-modell-lastige Herangehensweise und das dann zu kombinieren mit eigentlich agiler Softwareentwicklung und kontinuierlicher Verbesserung eigentlich auch von deiner Software ist ein bisschen schwierig, aber möglich. Du hast halt auch eine extreme Dokumentationslast, was das Ganze dann so ein bisschen weniger agil macht. Aber was jetzt zum Beispiel auch relativ neu gefordert und relativ wichtig ist, sind regelmäßig Usability-Tests. Du musst also nachweisen, dass deine Software muss nicht unbedingt oder generell dein System muss nicht unbedingt schön sein, aber der Benutzer muss das tun können, was er kann. Da gab es halt so schöne klassische oder weniger schöne Sachen in einer Software, die Bestrahlung gesteuert hat. Also bei Krebspatienten, die werden halt bestrahlt und die Software dafür hatte halt eine kleine grüne Lampe. Und die hat mal geleuchtet und mal nicht geleuchtet. Was man klassischerweise denkt, grüne kleine Lampe, alles ist gut. Nur, dass in dem Fall grüne kleine Lampe hieß, ja der Laser bestrahlt gerade. Und das heißt, die haben quasi nicht mitbekommen, dass die Patienten bestrahlt werden, gab Verbrennung und teilweise Tote. Also das ist dann, das ist schon, Usability im Medizinbereich, so grundlegende Sachen sind nicht so...
Ja, aber Software wird halt auch ohnehin immer missionskritischer, weil sie eben überall ist so. Deswegen bin ich ja schon lange der Meinung, Usability, Benutzbarkeit, einfach Offensichtlichkeit von Systemen muss einfach mitgedacht werden und das ja...
Ich fand das auch so ein bisschen augenöffnend jetzt in dem Projekt, den ich, was ich mit zwei Designern halt zusammen gemacht hab, wo halt wirklich sehr, sehr viel nutzerzentriert gearbeitet wurde. Wie sehr das, selbst wenn du im Backend arbeitest, weil halt auch jemand gestern, sei schon, in den Kommentaren zur letzten Sendung halt meinte, so auch Backend-Nerds sollten sich bitte nicht vor Usability so wehren. Dass es halt dein Denken verändert, wie du den Nutzer wahrnimmst, selbst wenn du was im Backend machst. Aber wenn du so grob weißt, wie Nutzer arbeiten mit einem System, wie Nutzer denken während sie arbeiten mit einem System, das hilft dir halt schon so, ja so ein bisschen zielorientierter halt auch zu entwickeln und ich fand das ungemein erleuchtend.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen, was ich ein bisschen schade finde, dadurch, dass du halt wirklich diese stark vorgegebenen Strukturen und teilweise auch Rollen hast. Also klar, für große Firmen kann ich das absolut verstehen. Das muss halt durch mehrere iterationen durchpabbeln und von Person A zu Person B zu Person C. Aber wir sind halt nur drei Leute. Und wir müssen jetzt halt gucken, dass wir quasi diese kompletten Rollenbilder von Qualitätsmanagement beauftragt haben. Security Officer, Safety Officer, Sales Management, Support.
Habt ihr auch schon eine Brandschutzbeauftragte? Ne, brauchen wir das ab 10.
Aber wir brauchen zum Beispiel erste Hilfe. Aber das wird nicht mehr zertifiziert.
Na bloß gut.
Also das ist alles so Arbeitsschutz, ist nicht zertifizierungsrelevant.
Also diese ISO Norm, die du vorhin ja genannt hast, diese 13485, ist ja im Prinzip im Kern so ein ISO 9001 Qualitätsstandards-Dingsie. Wo es um Nachvollziehbarkeit von Prozessen und Reproduktionsfähigkeit von Herstellungsvorgängen und so weiter geht.
Hatten wir das nicht auch in der ersten Firma, diesen Prozess mal angestoßen?
Weiß ich nicht. Weiß ich nicht, kann sein, aber ich bin mir nicht der...
Da gab es nämlich auch diesen ganzen Dokumentationsfuhr.
Man will es und man muss es und gleichzeitig will man es eigentlich nicht, zumindest nicht als Entwickler.
Ja, und wahrscheinlich auch nicht in dieser krassen Detailiertheit, wo man selber noch nicht weiß, ob das so...
Ja, also du musst halt ja iterativ dann auch die Prozesse anpassen. Und wenn du was an den Prozessen anpasst, musst du das halt wieder zum Notified Body. Und der Notified Body sagt dann, ja ist alles in Ordnung oder... Nee, das gefällt mir jetzt nicht so. Ich nehme euch eure Zertifizierung weg.
Wäre das nicht total praktisch, so ein Git-Zertifizierungsmodell zu haben, wo du so deine Versionen quasi so nach hinten dann so tracken kannst, über deine einzelnen Commits, aber wo du so quasi ein Commit ist, ein so ein Zertifizierungs... Na wie heißt das? Also ja, naja genau, aber ich meine so genau, hier das ist jetzt Version XY, okay, Produkt, also weil ihr benutzt Visual Studio, Visual Studio hat sich was geändert, wir müssen alles nochmal durchatterieren. Nächste Commit befasst sich halt genau damit.
Meine, die technische Dokumentation, die Qualitätsmanagement Dokument, da hab ich eben Git drin.
Nee, ich meine so, das wär halt geil, dass das so ein Standard wäre, wenn man eh schon als Entwickler, also welcher Entwickler nutzt nicht Git?
Das machen wir alles mit Git.
Du musst Dokumenten kontrollen, du musst nachweisen, was sich in bestimmten Dokumenten geändert haben.
Hättest du jetzt hier nicht so eine Horde Nerds sitzen, sondern so eine Hörde... Sondern so eine Härde, wie heißt das? Was soll ich sagen?
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
So ein paar Hipster, die dann um eine Ecke kommen mit, das kann dir die Blockchain lösen. Willst du das hören?
Oh ja, da kam wirklich jemand.
Aber Git ist doch eine Blockchain.
Dieses Prinzip, was du da auch abwählen kannst.
Ich habe die Frage bekommen von jemand anderem, ob man nicht die komplette technische Dokumentation und Qualitätsmanagementsystem in der Blockchain speichern sollte. Nein, sollte man nicht.
Doch, Git.
Git ist keine...
Sondern?
Das ist keine Blockchain, weil die Dinger ja nicht verkryptet, da gibt es ja keinen Proof of Work.
Gitcoin, ja, das ist jetzt noch das, was wir brauchen. Aber du kannst in Git keinen alten Eintrag ändern, ohne dass sich alle Hashes bis zum neuesten Eintrag ändern würden. Das ist genau das Prinzip einer Blockchain. Ob das Proof of Work braucht oder nicht, ist ja erstmal noch eine ganz andere Frage.
Okay, jetzt wirst du... Okay, du bringst einen guten Punkt auf. Habe ich jetzt noch nicht drüber.
Und warum die Blogs sagen, ist eigentlich auch mal, lass das mal weg. Blogs sind Daten so. Eigentlich ist das eine Chain, eine Hedge-Chain.
Es geht ja auch darum zu sagen, was ist jetzt hier die gültige Version. Das gibt es ja so, aber gibt nicht. Das ist egal. Na gut, kannst weggen. Ja, aber gültig ist, was du haben möchtest. Es gibt nicht eine Einigung darauf, was das eine echte ist, wo man dran aufbauen muss.
Aber niemand kann einen alten Eintrag ändern, ohne dass es sich bemerkbar machen würde. Das ist eigentlich das Prinzip einer Blockchain.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass es das Prinzip einer Blockchain ist, sondern es ist ein Aspekt einer Blockchain, der an der Stelle erfüllt wird und anderer Aspekte der Blockchain.
Die Sache ist auch nicht, ist es möglich oder ist es nicht möglich, sondern ist es notwendig.
Bei was jetzt? Bei deinem Kram?
Ja, bei meinem Kram.
Generell ist es immer die Frage, bei Blockchain ist es notwendig und die Antwort ist nein.
Das darfst du nun nicht den ganzen Leuten sagen, die gerade Forschungsanträge auf irgendwelche Blockchain-Scheiße gemacht haben. Was ich da letztens schon wieder gehört hab, wirklich so, ja wir wollen ein partizipatives für Stadtplanung, Git. Ah, naja, aber eigentlich Blockchain. Ich so, ja, könnt ihr mit Git machen. Ja, jetzt haben wir ja schon so einen Anfang bestellt auf Blockchain.
Blockchain, Git, alles klar, haben wir doch.
Git-Chain.
Blockcoin und Git-Chain.
Jetzt will ich aber mal wissen, was hältst du denn von dieser Idee, mit dem EKG in der Uhr? Also irgendwie, damit das nicht zurückblättert. Ja, ja, weil das mit der Blockchain bringt uns jetzt nicht weiter. Irgendjemand meinte vorhin, er hat im Chat noch auf dieses andere Produkt verwiesen, was es da gab, Cardia Band, das ist halt so ein Armband für die Uhr, die aber nicht einen digitalen Connector hat, weil sowas gibt es ja nicht. Und auch nicht über Bluetooth verbunden ist, sondern die Daten tatsächlich per Audio rüber schickt. Interessant.
Wartet ihr alle über Audio-Schnittstellen drüber fummeln, weil sie keine Ahnung haben?
Das ist gerade so ein bisschen der heiße Scheiß, dass man auch verdeckte Kommunikationen darüber macht. Also auch so Abhörmechanismen. Du generierst halt Ultraschall und die Mikrofone in den Uhren und Telefonen sind halt in der Lage, das noch zu dekodieren, aber du hast es halt nicht. Deswegen hast du unbemerkte Kommunikation. Aber es wird eben auch hier zur Datenübertragung genutzt. In dem Fall eben von diesem Kardia-Band. Und nun die neue Apple Watch hat es halt drin. Entsprechenden Sensor da, wo normalerweise nur der Puls-Sensor war. Und dann halt der zweite Kontakt mit dem Finger auf dem Rädchen. Und dann hast du da diese Schleife hergestellt und kannst ein einfaches EKG machen.
Also ich kann ja jetzt nur meine persönliche Meinung abgeben. Ich hätte gerne die Frohdaten. Mich würde echt interessieren, wie hoch die Abtastrate ist und was für Daten tatsächlich rauskommen. Ob man zum Beispiel als Arzt auch tatsächlich an eine schöne EKG-Kurve rankommen würden. Und wie viel...
Was heißt denn eine schöne?
Die da zu sehen.
Also einfach, ob man wirklich ein Zeitsignal hat, ein komplettes Zeitsignal. Oder ob das halt wirklich nur, wie zum Beispiel bei den Fitness-Trackern oder Aktivitäts-Trackern, du hast halt schon Messwerte. Und die werden dann über verschiedene Algorithmen, etwa Rule-Base oder AI oder sonst was, quasi geclustert. Und dann ist gesagt, okay, diese Wust aus verschiedenen Parametern scheint jetzt sitzen zu sein. Und dieser Wust aus verschiedenen Parametern scheint jetzt, keine Ahnung, peak zu sein. Also, ich weiß halt nicht, ob...
Du kriegst einen PDF-Fast, einen Report mit den Graphen einfach komplett.
Also...
Genau.
Ich will doch selber drauf analysieren.
Rohdaten, keine Ahnung, ob sie...
Du willst halt statistische Analysen machen und nicht so wie ein Arzt, der so drauf kommt.
Signalanalysen und dann die Statistiken.
Nee, die werden bestimmt keinen API-Zugriff auf die Dinger drin haben. Aber ich, keine Ahnung, was da...
Aber Rohdaten könnte es schon auch sein, dass ein Arzt sagt, ja okay, hier optisch, die Grafen sehen zwar ganz schick aus, aber ich brauch mal die Rohdaten.
Mit Rohdaten meinst du halt jetzt wirklich das, was direkt vom Sensor kommt.
Wir würden auch die Signale in einer automatisiert verarbeitbar Form reichen. Also mich interessiert halt jetzt nicht, na zur Not kann ich, wenn das PDF irgendwie Vektor-Grafik macht.
Also ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung, aber üblicherweise läuft das ja auf iOS so, dass halt alles, was Health-Data ist, landet in diesem Health-Kit. Also du hast halt diesen Storage, wo dann andere Apps andocken können und die auch auslesen können. Wie detailliert die dann sind, weiß ich nicht.
Lass dir doch mal so ein Sample geben von Apple.
Aber darf ich nicht nur meine eigenen Daten an?
Vielleicht kannst du dann schon mit EKG Sachen spielen, bevor die das hier freischalten.
Hätte ich Zeit? Ja, das ist so ein kleiner Punkt.
Ist ja auch erst mal egal. Du musst das ja jetzt nicht gleich komplett aufhacken. Ich wollte halt nur wissen, was du so generell...
Doch, doch, doch! Das ist doch das Spannende, warum wir hier sitzen. Ja, alles an Daten mal einfach angucken, was da tatsächlich rauskommt. Und auch dann kann man ja erst sagen, wie gut können die Algorithmen überhaupt sein und wie genau kann das Ganze sein?
Mir ist schon wieder Hacker eingetreten.
Ich mach's ja nicht kaputt, ich gucke nur.
Du hast mein vollstes Verständnis.
Also ich glaube, der größte Gewinn sind nicht die Leute, die jetzt am EKG sehen, dass sie da irgendwelche Fehler haben, sondern wirklich die Daten, die sie da sammeln, um vielleicht sogar noch mehr Fehler zu erkennen. Oder auch zu sehen, hier guck mal da irgendwie...
Feinere Diagnostik.
Ein Promille hat irgendwie folgendes Problem, aber die nächsten zehn Jahre lang ist von denen ja kein einziger deswegen umgefallen. Also scheint es gar nicht so schlimm zu sein. Irgendwie so.
Jetzt noch mal eine Frage. Also vielleicht mal so ausgehend. Die Apple Watch scheint sich ja gerade so ein bisschen zu so einem Medizinwerkzeug zu entwickeln. Das ist definitiv ein Markt, den Apple da sieht. Neben Fitnesskram.
Die nehmen den Fitnesskram und versuchen ihn jetzt in den Medizinbereich zu bringen. Also das, was geht.
Ja gut, EKG würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt als Fitnessfeature bezeichnen.
Puls beim Laufen.
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht ein EKG.
Nee, aber das ist halt so die Vorstufe. Also das ist generell so ein guter Ansatz. Alles, was du als Fitness bezeichnest, musst du halt nicht zertifizieren lassen. Weil es ist nur Fitness, es hat keine medizinische Indikation.
Darauf wollte ich auch nicht hinaus. Meine Frage ist eher, was zeichnet sich denn so ab, was man vielleicht am Handgelenk noch Interessantes tun kann? Abnehmen, erfassen, auswerten kann?
Das, was jetzt gerade so vor allem in Parkinson oder aber auch Geriatrie kommt, sind tatsächlich so die nächste Generation von Fitness-Trackern oder Aktivität-Trackern im Prinzip. Hast du halt Geräte am Handgelenk und die messen deine Bewegung? Also zum einen allgemeine Aktivität. Sitzt du, stehst du, läufst du. Genau. Das aber dann tatsächlich auch in medizinische, also in medizinisch für diagnostische Zwecke verwenden. Zum Beispiel bei Parkinson verschlimmern sich deine.
Tränenohr und so.
Genau. Tränenohr ist halt, da brauchst du dann so eine gewisse höhere Frequenz. Also da reicht normaler Fitness-Tracker nicht. Freezing of gait mit Bewegung am Handgelenk wird versucht zu analysieren.
Also dieses Freezing war so vorhin schon?
Ja.
Also feststellen, dass jemand sich nicht mehr bewegt?
Aktiv diese spezifischen Symptome zeigt. Also dass er sich erst anscheinend normal läuft, dann tippelt oder sich versteift und dann sich nicht mehr bewegt. Ist aus meiner Sicht so ein bisschen schwierig, weil aus verschiedenen Gründen zum Beispiel Handgelenk sind halt nicht die Füße. Es gibt so ein typisches Parkinson-Bild. Die haben halt immer die Hände relativ steif und fest, weil die einfach einen verringerten Bewegungsumfang haben und die können sich nicht so leicht bewegen. Da wird viel Bewegung, aber auch Sozialanalyse gemacht. Wie viel bewegt sich der Patient? Geht er raus? Geht er nicht raus? Das wird dann auch teilweise bei depressiven Patienten versucht. Hat er gerade wieder eine depressive Phase? Geht er raus? Geht er nicht raus? Wie sind die Sozialkontakte?
Du meinst, man könnte vielleicht am Handgelenk messen, ob man gerade depressiv ist?
Das versuchen Leute. Das versuchen Forschungsgruppen.
Und dann fängt die Uhr an, mit einem zu reden, wie so ein kleines Bokemon?
Das weiß ich nicht. Das ist halt so... Man versucht, also... Man hat halt diese Denkweise. Man kann jetzt so viele schöne Daten aufnehmen. Also tun wir das mal. Und wir wenden das einfach mal auf alles Mögliche an Krankheiten an, wo wir noch nicht wissen, wie wir damit umgehen. Das ist halt tatsächlich, je mehr Daten, je besser. Und ich hab einen schönen Artikel gelesen über einen Sensor, den man sich quasi an die Stirn dann bringen kann. Es ist noch Hardware-Forschung. Und die kontrollieren deinen Puls, Temperatur, Hautfeuchtigkeit und Leitfähigkeit. Also alles, was so eine Uhr aufmacht.
Zu denen an die Stirn.
Weil der zusätzlich deine Sozialinteraktion scannt.
Mit Kamera oder was?
Ich weiß nicht, was die da alles einbauen.
Das nächste Apple-Produkt, iBindi.
Ja, im Prinzip passieren viele Entwicklungen.
Da sind wir wieder bei deiner Badge.
Stimmt, der iBindi. Das ist super, das ist genau das Richtige fürs Scamp. Jeder klebt sich so eine Kamera auf die Stirn. Das wird bestimmt gut ankommen.
Mit Sicherheit.
Dauert doch nicht mehr eine bis zum Kommunikator.
Ralf, mal weiter. Ich finde das cool. Was macht der iBindi dann genau? Der misst Haut, Spannung, Elektrik?
Der soll alles Mögliche messen. Es ist ein preliminary Forschungsprodukt, wo sie im Prinzip sagen, wir nehmen so viele Daten wie möglich auf, weil wir Patienten mit Depressionen helfen. Und das ist halt so ein Ansatz, den ich immer extrem kritisch finde. Weil im Prinzip...
Entschuldigung, ich hab sie gedrückt.
Du musst sie festhalten, nicht nur drücken. Ist ja ein Taster und kein Schalter.
Jetzt wissen alle, dass du heimlich im Platin bist.
Der Sensor soll, glaube ich, auch analysieren, was du isst.
Na gut, aber vielleicht können wir noch mal so ein bisschen spinnen, mit was wäre am Handgelenk möglich. Ich meine, dass man überall irgendwas applizieren kann, ist klar. Aber es geht ja hier auch um dieses Casual-Use.
Ich hab das einfach unter dem Passiv. Ich denke, was auf jeden Fall noch mal interessant wird, Hautleitfähigkeit gibt es, glaube ich, schon. Zumindest einen anderen. Schweißanalyse, Elektrolyte, Annäherungszustand. Hast du dich angestrengt? Hast du dich nicht angestrengt? Hast du trockene Haut? Brauchst du vielleicht dieses Feuchtigkeitsprodukt für deine Haut? Warst du schon wieder zwei Tage nicht duschen?
Das könnte nerds wirklich helfen.
Aber nur, wenn man das auf dem Kongress auf alle zwölf Stunden so ein Notifier geduschen.
Ja, geduschen.
Da kannst du aber auch einfach so Geruchssensoren im Gang aufhängen und immer los tüten, wenn irgendwie zu viel olfaktorische Flatulenz am Start ist.
Ich glaube, das, was tatsächlich nochmal sehr, sehr spannend wird, sind genaue, also es gibt schon die Möglichkeit, den Sauerstoffsättigungsgehalt noninvasiv zu checken. Also da hast du dann halt so eine Leuchtdiode, die quasi den Finger durchleuchtet. Und du kannst dann, je nachdem, wie viel, von welchem Lichtspektrum auf dem im Mitte kommt, kannst du quasi den Sauerstoffgehalt berechnen. Sowas könntest du halt rein theoretisch auch am Handgelenk machen. Ja und ja. Also es gibt, glaube ich, rein theoretisch auch Ansätze, wo du halt einfach nur eine Art Reflektion nutzt. Aber da bin ich zu weit weg von, ich glaube, irgendwann hören, sagen.
Ich fühlte mich auch an, wir hatten so ein Ding in unserem Studium.
Marco meinte im Chat, das sind ja glaube ich so ein bisschen so heilige Graldinger. Blutzucker.
Blutzucker wäre der Wahnsinn.
Ja vor allem am Handgelenk hat das halt den elegant.
Also Blutdruck geht doch nicht, oder mit so einer Uhr?
Rein theoretisch könntest du den Blutdruck überall messen, aber das ist so fein, da weiß ich nicht, weiß ich nicht, ob das geht.
Wird dann einfach mal die Uhr? Die schnallt sich dann fest.
So, die macht es. Eine Uhr, die sich selber festmacht, wäre sowieso nochmal ganz gut. Aber bleiben wir mal realistisch. Blutzucker optisch?
Ich weiß, dass es Sensoren gibt, die über den Schweiß, glaube ich, Blutzucker messen. Das Problem ist, dass der eine relativ starke Verzögerung hat. Also der, ich glaube 20 Minuten war so das Problem, dass wenn du einen Drop im Blutzucker hast, musst du halt relativ akut handeln. Und wenn du das erst 20 Minuten später im Schweiß siehst, oder an der Hautkonnektivität oder sonst was, also irgendwas noninvasives, dann ist das im Normalfall zu spät. Deshalb ist derzeit immer noch, du brauchst Blut. Und da gibt es halt tatsächlich so Patches, die du dann einfach in, vielleicht jetzt finde ich dich nicht das ganz Richtige tun.
Und von uns her hat das auch, der packt die Dinger rein, die bleiben dann zwei Wochen drin, die pieksen sich so ein bisschen da in die Epidermis rein und haben NFC. Und dann kannst du einfach das Telefon an den Sticker ranhalten und der sagt dir halt, wie es dir gerade geht.
Genau. Wenn es da halt, also da gibt es bestimmt Untersuchungen, das ist auch komplett noninvasiv, dadurch, dass du hier halt so Adern hast und eine relativ dünne Haut, weiß ich nicht, wäre cool, wenn es geht.
Ja, vor allem, dass du halt nicht mehr aktiv, dass da rangehen musst.
Also es muss nicht mehr invasiv sein, das wäre halt schön.
Ja, auch das Ding, worüber Tim redet, ist halt so ein Buffel, den du am Oberarm hast und wo du aber mit dem Telefon noch mal rangehst, um den Wert abzulesen. Und das wäre halt super. Aber was du halt sagtest, ist ja genau die Spanne, wenn dann doch mal der Blutzucker extrem runterfällt. Das kann halt wirklich so in einem sehr knappen Zeitfenster halt passieren, dass du eigentlich schon von deiner Uhr so einen Hinweis bekommst, hey, so in den letzten fünf Minuten ist dein Blutzucker runtergegangen. Und zwar auf eine Art und Weise, der unnatürlich ist.
Vor allem, es gibt inzwischen sehr schöne, in Anführungszeichen, Algorithmen, die auch relativ gut berechnen können für dich individuell über AI, wie viel Insulin du tatsächlich brauchst, weil das ist so hoch individuell, dass das relativ schwierig ist einzustellen und auszurechnen mit herkömmlichen Wegen. Und da gibt es halt wirklich Apps, die dann auch versuchen oder teilweise auch machen, im Prinzip deine Insulindose zu berechnen. Und wenn du halt tatsächlich so komplett noninvasiv einfach nur die Uhr am Handgelenk hast und die dich erinnert von wegen, hey, jetzt solltest du Insulin nehmen und das und das ist deine Dosis. Und halt am besten dann noch kombiniert mit automatisch analysiert, was hast du gerade gegessen? Ähm, doch, aber nur am Anfang. Da kommt zu wenig an im Körper, da wo du es brauchst. Also ich glaube, es gibt Insulin-Tabletten, die werden halt so bei leichten Formen gegeben. Aber im Normalfall willst du das so schnell und akut und auch präzise haben, dass das nicht reicht.
Also ich meine, da würden die das ja sofort verkaufen.
Ja, es gibt aber zum Beispiel auch ein Medizin-Produkt, das ist so ein automatischer Pen, der im Prinzip genau dosiert so und so viel Insulin abgibt. Das ist halt auch nochmal eine Sache. Wie viel Insulin bekommt jetzt eigentlich der Patient und wie viel spritzt er sich? Spritzt er sich zu viel, spritzt er sich zu wenig? Das genau kontrollieren ist halt auch noch so ein wichtiger Faktor. Aber dass die Uhr jetzt direkt Insulin gibt, direkt Medikamente abgeben, dann wär's definitiv ein Medizinprodukt.
Aber gibt's da noch irgendwas, was man... Also du hast ja vorhin schon erwähnt, für diesen Tremor bräuchte man einen deutlich feiner auflösenden Bewegungssensor.
Ich denke...
Damit hat ja jetzt die neue Apple Watch auch gebrochen.
Genau, ich denke, mit der Apple Watch kann man Tremor erkennen. Es ist halt die Sache, die muss dann eigentlich den ganzen Tag lang laufen. Und es gibt unterschiedliche Arten von Tremor. Es gibt einen Ruhe-Tremor, es gibt einen Initiativ-Tremor. Ich kenne nur den englischen Begriff. Es gibt einen Haltetremor, es gibt einen Aktionstremor. Im Prinzip hängt das auch davon ab, was gerade der Patient macht. Liegt seine Hand einfach nur ruhig rum? Oder hält er gerade den Arm? Das sind halt dann unterschiedliche Tremor. Und es gibt halt je nach Erkrankung auch unterschiedliche Tremor-Arten. Also essenzieller Tremor ist zum Beispiel was anderes als ein Parkinson-Tremor. Die haben dann andere Frequenzen. Und rein theoretisch könnte man das daran super unterscheiden. Also so reine oder auch Finger-Tremor. Kann man mit Handgelenkenmessungen eventuell Finger-Tremor beim Schreiben detektieren.
Also für mich klingt das jetzt nicht so unwahrscheinlich. Weil, ich meine, sie haben ja jetzt auch diese Fallerkennung zum Beispiel auch drin.
Ja, das ist relativ einfach, denke ich. Das ist aus meiner Sicht halt nicht neu.
Sie meinten, das was sie jetzt in der Öffentlichkeit gesagt haben, keine Ahnung, meistens ist eine Funken Wahrheit dahinter, dass sie diesen neuen, hochauflösenden Bewegungssensor brauchten, um zuverlässig diese Fallgeschichte zum Beispiel zu machen.
Ich lese halt sowas teilweise schon in medizinischen Publikationen, wo sie halt dann nicht die Apple Watch nehmen, aber im Prinzip gab es ja da schon eine große Entwicklung vorweg, bis das in der Apple Watch gelandet ist.
Das ist so für mich nicht die allerersten. Das Besondere daran ist ja nur, es handelt sich halt einfach mal um eine fucking Uhr.
Ja, aber ich denke, das ist nur freigeschaltet, wenn man 60 über 60 ist.
Automatisch.
Automatisch eingeschaltet kannst du es natürlich selber.
Ja, wobei es auch dann so viel falsch positive berichtet wurden. Und da bin ich halt zum Beispiel auch, ist es ein Medizinprodukt, weil stellt es...
Was meinst du mit falsch positive? Also ich hab da noch nicht so viel gesehen. Es gab hier neulich diesen schönen Test.
Von der Joanna Stern oder wie das heißt?
Genau, wo sie sich irgendwie so eine Stuntwoman irgendwie geholt hat, um so Stürze nachzustellen und so zu unterscheiden zwischen ich tu nur so und jetzt bin ich wirklich gefallen. Und das war soweit ich das...
Sie musste sich schon ordentlich hinschmeißen, damit es gegen einen Anschlag ging.
Genau, also die musste schon the real thing machen.
Ist dieser Sturz-Sensor halt zertifiziert? Ist es ein Medizinprodukt? Oder ist es halt im weitesten Sinne Konsumerprodukt und hat keinen Anspruch?
Ich glaube, diese ganze FDA-Geschichte war nur im Zusammenhang mit dem EKG.
Also das wäre halt noch sehr interessant, weil dann...
Aber wieso Medizinprodukt? Ist ja keins. So wie ein Feuermelder ja auch die Feuerwehr ruft, aber kein Medizinprodukt ist.
Nee, das nicht, aber ein Sturz kann eine medizinische Indikation sein.
Ja gut, was ja passiert ist, wenn du stürzt, dann kommt das Ding hoch und sagt...
Bist du gestürzt, du musst dann eine Minute hast du Zeit, um zu sagen, ja nee, ist alles okay.
Und dann ruft er halt irgendwie automatisch.
Ist das eine Diagnose?
Wie ist es denn mit den Dingern hier für alte Leute in dem Haus, diese Notrufssysteme, das Prinzip ist doch dasselbe.
Ja genau, da bin ich mir halt auch nicht sicher, ob die als, wahrscheinlich sind sie nicht als Medizinprodukt zugelassen. Andererseits ist eine Gehilfe auch ein Medizinprodukt.
Es stürzt Strümpfe auch, wie ich gerade gelesen habe.
Ja klar.
Ich würde sagen, es ist kein Medizinprodukt, weil der misst ja nicht, dass du nach dem Sturz Schaden hast, sondern der misst ja nur, dass du gestürzt bist.
Das lustige ist, bei solchen Geräten ist nicht, was das Gerät selbst macht, sondern als was du es verkaufst. Was versprichst du mit diesem Gerät? Wenn du sagst, wenn du medizinischen Benefit versprichst von der Benutzung dieses Gerätes, dann ist es ein Medizinprodukt.
Aber ist die Feuerwehr rufen medizinischer Benefit?
Nee, weil es nichts mit Medizin und keine Diagnose hat. Wenn es auf Patienten angewendet wird, wenn du also einen patientenspezifischen Feueralarm hast, der auf Hand von gemessenen Daten eine Diagnose erstellt und dann sagt, der ruft jetzt die Feuerwehr aufgrund von dieser Diagnose.
Aber Diagnose ist doch immer am Menschen, oder? Der Sturz ist ja nicht...
Ja, das ist keine medizinische Diagnose. Das ist ja nicht auf Basis von, was dein Körper sagt, sondern auf Basis von, wie dein Körper sich gerade durch die Luft bewegt. Oder nach vorne.
Und dann nach unten.
Und dann nach unten, ja.
Stimmt, die hätte mal gegen die Wand laufen können.
Ich meine, allein schon so zu unterscheiden, diese drei Fallarten, die sie da haben, also das ist so ein Stolpern, ein reines Fallen und ein... Was war das? Ausrutschen. Ausrutschen, sozusagen. Da durften sie schon eine ganze Menge AI und Maschinenlearning durchgeschossen haben.
Sie haben bestimmt so einen Dummy aufs Eis geschickt und haben den da mal fallen lassen.
Na ja, das ist halt ihre Stärke jetzt. Jetzt haben sie halt da diese ganze Neural Power. Und ich weiß nicht, inwiefern sie das jetzt auch schon in diesem Bewegungsdetektor, ob der ist ja eigentlich mit auf dem Prozessor jetzt mittlerweile drauf. Ist der da schon voll integriert?
Die haben doch diesen M-Dingens-Chip da, M4.
Ja, aber hat der selber auch solche AI-Cores, dass er quasi diese ganze Detection...
Glaub ich nicht, da die AI-Cores ja in dem A, welchen Nummer auch immer die haben drin ist.
Na ja, wenn das Ding ohne die CPU anzuschmeißen halt die ganze Zeit in Realtime alles trecken soll, muss das Ding ja im Prinzip selber in der Lage sein, diese Modelle zu exekutieren. Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass sie da so einen einfachen Core drin haben, der jetzt nicht so auf Hochleistung ist.
So oft passt der so viel G nicht an Beschleunigung, das heißt, immer wenn das mal ist, dann kann er...
Das hat nichts mit G zu tun, das hat einfach was zu tun. Das Ding muss ja die ganze Zeit permanent erkennen, was machst du eigentlich gerade, ohne dass die ganze Zeit die CPU deswegen läuft. Weil du läufst ja die ganze Zeit. Mittlerweile ist ja bei der Uhr so auch jetzt hier bei der alten, mit dem neuen Update, wenn ich jetzt hier am Stück irgendwie einen Kilometer laufe, kommt dann irgendwann die Uhr und sagt, du läufst ja hier irgendwie schon seit einem Kilometer, machst du vielleicht gerade Training? Und dann kannst du sagen, ja. Und dann wird das als einen Training aufgezeichnet, rückwirkend. Und der weiß auch, ob du läufst oder gehst. Das heißt, das Ding ist schon permanent aware. Das haben sie ja auch schon vorher gemacht, durch diese Ringe und so weiter. Sie unterscheiden stehen, laufen.
Können sie stehen und sitzen, separat unterscheiden?
Sagen sie, wie zuverlässig das ist.
Genau. Wir hatten nämlich mal eine kleine Studie, wo im Prinzip wir so ein medizinisches Armband, also das ist dann zugelassen für medizinische Analysen, hat so unsere Genauigkeit gerade. Und im Prinzip hat das auch gleiche Basis. Konnte halt Anzahl der Schritte, Bewegungsaktivität, also Stehen, Sitzen, Training, Liegen, Schlafen, angeblich alles unterscheiden. Hat halt auch Hautaktivität, also Hautschweiß, elektrische Leitfähigkeit gemessen und konnte daraus dann angeblich sogar zu einem gewissen Genauigkeitsgrad Kalorienverbrauch estimieren. Und der war halt im Prinzip für medizinische Nutzen soweit zugelassen. Und da haben wir halt mal so ein bisschen mit rumgespielt und ein paar Patienten und gesunde Kontrollen gemessen. Und zumindestens mit deren Algorithmus war das extrem schwierig, tatsächlich eine genaue Aktivitäts-Tracking hinzubekommen. Da wird sich hoffentlich sehr viel getan haben. Die Firma selbst gibt es auch nicht mehr, weil die wurde, glaube ich, von Fitbit aufgekauft. Und jetzt gibt es auch den Sensor nicht mehr. Das heißt, ja.
Ich denke, das Medizin-Thema ist jetzt...
Ich kann euch noch die anderen Isos vorlesen, damit ihr einschläft.
Nein. Nicht schön.
Warum sollte ich? Aber ich hab keine Zeit, die Daten auszuwerten.
Also brauch ich so eine.
Du kommst dir eh nicht ran.
Pff, nicht gesagt.
Ich hab keine Zeit für meine... Also ich brauch nicht noch mehr Daten, die ich nicht auswerten kann. Ich hab 100 Terabyte an Medizindaten, die ich nicht in Ruhe auswerten kann.
Weil du zu wenig Computer hast?
Weil ich zu wenig Zeit habe, um die Algorithmen zu bauen.
Tim einstellen, der macht dir bestimmt den ganzen Dokumentationsfonds für die Zertifizierung. Ist fast wie Buchhaltung, Tim. Wie wär's?
Das stimmt nicht.
Das ist dann so ein bisschen Big Data, ja? Und dann kann man da so mit Tools dann statistisch...
Nee, es ist nicht Big Data.
Es ist sparse Data.
Noch mehr oder wie?
Nein, nein. Das sind spärliche Daten. Also das Problem... Big Data kann alles Mögliche sein. Aber wir haben halt nicht die 50 Millionen Tausend Datensätze, sondern wir haben einfach große Daten. Das ist ein Unterschied.
Wie viele Datensätze sind an deiner 100 Terabyte?
Na, wir haben allein 80 Terabyte von Schlafdaten. Ein Patient eine Nacht, sind ein Terabyte an Rohdaten. Von 3D.
Was hast du das gemessen? Ach, der ganze Körper sozusagen, die ganze Bewegung.
Der komplette Kinect-Messbereich mit allen Daten, die da so anfallen. Das ist so acht Stunden, ein Terabyte. Und das ist schon auf eine Art komprimiert und dann noch mal gesitzt und ja.
Regional verkorkt.
Ja, der Rest sind so die 2000 Patientendaten, die wir so über die letzten Jahre an Studien angesammelt haben. Und der Patient hat halt 1 bis N Messzeitpunkte, wo er dann halt seine 10 bis 15 unterschiedlichen Tests durchgeführt hat und jeden Test dann noch in 1 bis 3 Wiederholungen. Also das ist so eigentlich ein sehr, sehr netter Datensatz. Und wir können schöne Analysen drauf machen. Muss auch jeder irgendwann mal schauen und ja. Wir haben nicht genug Doktoranden, die sich gerne damit befassen wollen, kostenlos für uns Daten auszuwählen.
Und es wird nicht besser. Du musst ja jetzt ja auch mal podcasten und so. Das geht natürlich auch in die Zeit.
Ich muss noch weiter postkasten?
Natürlich. So schnell kommst du aus der Nummer jetzt nicht raus.
Ich muss wieder weg.
Wir wollen ja hier den 50-50-Podcast einführen, dass hier die Quote irgendwie besser ist.
Ja, aber auch mindestens 50 Prozent reden.
Das übernimmt ja Tim schon. Letty sagt ja auch nicht so viel.
Wir haben uns letztes Mal so viel unterhalten.
Genau, das muss man immer dazusagen, vor der Sendung gemassregelt, dass wir hier nicht den erweiterten Monolog halten sollen.
Den Duolog habe ich gesagt.
Dann machen wir das jetzt einfach mal ganz einfach.
Ich habe genug geredet.
Dann wechseln wir jetzt einfach mal ganz krass das Thema.
Hast du eigentlich noch so ein Sound für etwas Außergewöhnliches?
Etwas Außergewöhnliches?
Ja, was ist ja...
Ein bisschen kurz?
Ja, mehr so im Style von Imperial March, nur nicht ganz so systematisch. Nee, das ist nicht der Imperial March. Also in der letzten Sendung, Freak Show berichtete, hab ich ja erzählt von der Mac Pro wird gerade mit neuen Boot-Roms versorgt innerhalb der Mojave...
Hab ich gemacht? Hab ich gemacht?...
dass. Die 5 Giga-Transactions irgendwie funktionieren. Das ist irgendwie so ein PCI 3 und PCI 2 Erkennungsding, was die da falsch erkannt haben. Und was war noch? Das EFI kann jetzt geflasht werden. Das Boot-Rom kann geflasht werden, wenn man eine EFI-Card hat oder irgendwie sowas vorher wohl nicht ging oder so. Also nicht so groß dramatisch, aber so ein bisschen vor allem, dass sie überhaupt was an den Boot-Rom für den Mac Pro...
Dass was Neues kommt.
Dass was Neues kommt. Also haben sie mit dem APFS ja schon vorher auch gemacht, aber dass sie jetzt immer noch dran schrauben, obwohl da jetzt nicht so wirklich Notwendigkeit besteht. So, dann kam jetzt die Mojave OST 10.14.1 Beta 1. Da kam das Boot-Rom 139. Keine größeren Änderungen waren erkennbar, aber es gab schon wieder ein Update. Und dann...
Also sozusagen das Punkt 1 Update von Mojave kommt dann auch wieder mit einem neuen Boot-Rom.
Genau. Und das ist in den Betas schon drin. Und jetzt vorgestern kam das Beta 3 davon mit wieder einem neuen Boot-Rom, nämlich die 140. Und jetzt ist das passiert, was keiner geahnt hätte, was ich vor zwei Wochen sagte, die müssten ja bei Apple nur dieses eine NVMe-Modul da reinschmeißen und nicht mehr tun. Und was haben sie gemacht? Sie haben sie jetzt reingeschmissen.
Nein.
Das heißt, die haben auf uns gehört.
Und noch viel besser, weil sie so einen Druck hatten, sind sie in der Zeit zurückgereist und haben das tatsächlich schon eine Woche vor unserer Sendung gemacht. Damals. Jetzt hast du dich gerade ausgeschaltet gehabt. Dein Wow ist untergegangen. Jedenfalls, das heißt, dass mit der 140, die gerade in dem Beta 3 drin ist und demnächst in dem 10.14.1 kommen wird, weil die normalen Leute sollen jetzt keine Betas installieren, wird die 140 ausgeliefert, mit der man dann von NVMe booten kann. Was heißt, dass man sich, ich nenne jetzt mal die Produkte, weil die Leute wollen das bestimmt wissen, die das machen wollen. Man kann sich jetzt eine Samsung 970 Evo oder Pro, je nachdem wie viel Geld man hat oder wie wichtig einem die Daten sind, kaufen mit dem passenden Adapter, zum Beispiel Lycom 120.
Also als M2.
Genau, M2 geht ja in den Mac Pro nicht rein, deswegen braucht man noch so einen Adapter, der ist auch passiv, der ist gar nicht so teuer. Also es gibt einen von Lycom, Lycom 120 heißt der irgendwie so. Musst mal gucken, L, Y, C, O, M. Also das Ding hier kannst du mal verlinken, weil das ist bewiesen, dass es funktioniert.
Welches Ding?
Diese 970 Evo oder 970 Pro. Weil die 950er, die geht wohl nicht. 960er soll wohl gehen, kann ich jetzt aber auch nicht garantieren. 970er aber wohl auf jeden Fall. So, dann machen wir noch hier, verlinken wir den Lycom 120.
Warte mal langsam. Also 970 Pro geht auch.
Ja, das sind ja mehr oder weniger beides die gleichen.
Die gibt es aber nur im halben Terra oder gibt es hier auch als Terra?
Ja, gibt es auch als Terra. Klick mal drauf, dann kannst du bei Amazon die Größe mal auswählen.
Ach so.
Wie das immer so ist. Manchmal meistens. Dann hast du das falsche Produkt erwischt.
Das war, geht nur bei Amazon direkt oder gut integriert in Dritt anwiedern.
Aber ich hab das zu Hause auch gemacht. Da kamen diese Auswahldinger. Konntest du zwischen Pro und Evo auswählen?
Wir hatten eben auch eine, wo du auswählen konntest.
Dann nimm noch wieder die Originale, die du hattest. Und genau da.
Naja, hier gibt es das auch als Tippe.
Und als Zweityppe sogar. Doch, dazwischen.
Ach, da.
Das sind die normalen Evo und nicht Evo Pro.
Guck mal, 540, das ist dann auch gar nicht mehr doppelt so teuer. Dann noch ein bisschen.
Das ist nicht Pro-Lahn.
Egal.
Muss schon Pro sein.
Jedenfalls, bevor wir völlig abkommen, tippt man noch den Adapter ein, weil das ist wichtig, weil ohne den gehen die nämlich alle gar nicht. Ich hab schon einer verlinkt. Kannst du den nehmen, glaube ich. Der müsste das sein. Genau, DT120, glaube ich, das ist der. Genau. Kannst du auch gleich den von Amazon nehmen, weil was der da verlinkt hat, ist jetzt ein bisschen, da kann man glaube ich nicht bestellen so easy.
Lykom.
Lykom 120, irgendwas. Dann müsste der schon, genau. Wir haben auch einen 129. Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur irgendwie so halbe Bauhöhe. Da bin ich mir nicht so 100% sicher, ob das jetzt komplett der gleiche ist. Der 120er tut aber auf jeden Fall, weil ich hab den schon zu Hause mit so einer Intel Octane Karte, die auch NVMe ist, aber hab ich nicht im Mac, sondern im PC, ist egal. Aber jedenfalls diese Adapterkarte funktioniert. Und wenn man jedenfalls diese Kombination jetzt in seinen Mac Pro reinsteckt, mit so einer Samsung zum Beispiel, dann kann man halt davon booten, was vorher nicht ging. Man konnte es zwar benutzen, aber nicht zum Booten. Definitiv. Also, haben die Leute schon gemacht. Es gibt schon einen Händler, der seine Mac Pros, seine alten, gibt es ja so Händler, die so alte Mac Pros verkaufen, der bietet die jetzt schon an mit NVMe Native Boot.
Bringt die?
Dreieinhalb Gigabyte die Sekunde. Nochmal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Dreieinhalb Gigabyte die Sekunde.
Alter, aber was...
Ja, Tim ist sprachlos.
Ja, ich überleg gerade, weil das sind ja einfach nochmal... Ich fand das ja schon immer so cool, dass man in diese Büchse so viel Zeug reinstecken kann. Jetzt geht da ja nochmal richtig was ab.
Also ich hatte ja vorher auch schon so einen Adapter in meinem Mac, wo halt irgendeine Apple SSD aus irgendeinem Mac Pro drin ist, von der ich bute. Das ist halt aber eben kein NVME, sondern es ist noch irgendwie so SATA über AHCI, und es ist auch so eine Spezial-Apple-SSD, damit wegen Trimmer und so weiter und so fort. Es geht alles, ist aber nicht so schick, und vor allem dieses SATA-AHCI ist auch nur so, ich komm so auf 600 Megabyte die Sekunde. Also es ist okay, aber es ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so, der Adapter ist auch so ein bisschen schräg, die Schraube passt irgendwie nicht, das hängt da so lose drin. Also irgendwie ist das alles so ein bisschen... Und jetzt mit diesen Dingen, die haben sich ja vorher schon das künstlich, wie ich ja erzählt hatte, selber rein injectet, dieses NVMe-Modul, also die haben das auch schon vor Apple selber gemacht, ging ja auch alles. Und da dachte ich schon, das werde ich auch eines Tages irgendwann mal machen, aber jetzt ist es halt von Apple in native da, das heißt jetzt ist es auch supported und wird auch bleiben und wenn ein Update kommt, ist es höchstwahrscheinlich von Apple dann auch wieder drin, weil die können das ja nicht einfach wieder entfernen, das Feature, weil ein Feature, was mal da ist, muss Apple ja dann auch weiter pflegen und das ist ja, also...
Was würdest du jetzt sagen, ist der Unterschied zwischen der Pro und der Evo?
Na, die Evo, die Pro wird mehr, wie sagt man, die Ausfall, wie werden diese Ausfallblöcke genannt, wenn sie mehr Blöcke haben als eigentlich angezeigt werden, dieser Spare-Bereich sozusagen.
Ja, also eine höhere Ausfallsicherheit.
Genau, wird sie das haben und dann nutzt sie auch eine andere Technik, das ist dann...
Bisschen schneller ist es auch noch.
Es ist schneller hält, also diese Endurance sozusagen, wie lange sie hält, ist deutlich besser und wenn sie fehlert, kann sie sich auch länger durch die kaputten, durch funktionierende ersetzen. Irgendwie so. Also...
Okay, aber die normale Evo gibt's aber dann auch in diesem 2TB. Und auf diesem Adapter...
Wo gibt's nicht einen 2TB?
Aber da passt nur eine drauf, ne?
Da passt nur eine drauf.
Es gibt doch auch welche mit 2. 4.
2 glaub ich auch, aber 4 ist der von Highpoint, musst du mal suchen, Highpoint M2 Adapter Quad oder irgendwie so. Da kann ich jetzt aber aus dem Kopf nicht gerade garantieren, ob der dann auch irgendwie...
Ist doch aber auch alle gleich, oder?
Nee, ich glaub bei dem Vierfachen, da ist noch mal so ein PCI-Chip drauf, der den Bus halt dann in vier Dinge aufteilt. Da bin ich mir halt nicht ganz so sicher.
D-Log. Ist doch auch richtig.
Was hab ich gesagt?
Da gibt's doch da oben D-Log PCI. Ah nee, über der roten. Da steht's auch viermal.
Also da kann ich jetzt aber aus dem Kopf nicht sagen, wie das so funktioniert. Aber bei dem Preis weiß ich jetzt gar nicht so, ob das so geht.
Da ist ja nicht viel drauf. Ich meine, M2 ist ja letzten Endes nichts anderes als direktes Interfacing in PCI, weil M2 ja auch nichts anderes ist.
Genau, aber du bist ja nur in einem PCI-Slot drin. Eigentlich müsste da dann noch ein Chip drauf sein, der das PCI dann auch viermal umdingst. So wie bei Grafikkarten, dass...
Die viermal was?
Na, du steckst ja in einen PCI-Slot, jetzt vier M2-Karten, das heißt, die vier wollen ja alle ihren eigenen PCI-Slot haben. Das heißt, da muss ein Chip drauf, der das dann so aufsplittet.
So verstehe ich das nicht. Ich meine, du kannst ja beliebig viele Devices haben, die über denselben Slot in den Bus reingehen. Du hast halt nur so und so viele Lanes zur Verfügung. Das ist die Beschränkung. Also du kannst nicht mehr Performance rauskriegen, aber du kannst über das eine PCI, natürlich mehrere PCI-Devices anschließen.
Bin ich mir jetzt gerade nicht so sicher, weil in dem Forum haben die immer von diesem Hi-Port oder wie auch immer, dass sie irgendwas mit Hi gelesen, was halt irgendwie inzwischen 400 Dollar kostet, weil da ein Port auf vier aufsplittet, wo man dann vier so eine Module einstecken kann.
Auf jeden Fall, wenn ich mir so ein Ding kaufe, dann kaufe ich mir natürlich mindestens gleich so einen Doppeladapter, weil dann kannst du halt noch mal eben...
Dann können wir das gleich hier berichten und wenn es nicht klappt, dann musst du halt noch mal den anderen holen. Da der aber nur 28 Euro kostet, kannst du ja mal den sauren Apfel beißen.
Ja.
Also ich hab mir diesen Lykon bestellt, der kommt leider aber erst nächsten Monat.
Aber warte mal, hier ist... Die sind nicht identisch. Das eine ist diese... Oh Gott, was war denn das nochmal? Das eine ist Key B, das andere ist Key M.
Ja, der kann wahrscheinlich gar nicht beide gleichzeitig, sondern du kannst entweder das eine Modul oder das andere Modul da reinstecken.
Was war denn nochmal Key B und Key M?
Ja, wenn das jetzt mal das ist, was Letty auch gerne wissen würde. Weil bei ihrem Laptop muss sie ja das...
Beziehungsweise ich weiß jetzt, dass es zwei Karten gibt, die in meinen Laptop reinpassen und dass ich... Ich hab grad schon zu Tala im Chat rumgeheult, dass die Karten von dem... von dieser Evo so verdammt günstig sind im Vergleich zu diesen Transcent-Karten.
Such dann nochmal diesen Highport, Highlock, wie ich... Ich hab den Namen vergessen, müsst ihr schnell gucken. Ich glaub, das, was du da gefunden hast, da kannst du nur entweder das eine oder das andere reinstecken. Das ist noch nicht das wahre, was man braucht.
Aber was zeichnet nochmal dieser Keykram?
Das sind die verschiedenen Kodierungen, die es da so gibt.
Formfaktoren und Keys.
Du könntest bei, wo habe ich das denn herausgefunden, es ist nicht bei iFixit, wo drauf steht, welche Karte zu dem Laptop passt.
Diese Key-ID sagt was.
Nein, Laptop ist ja wieder, da gibt es andere Baustelle.
Ich meine nicht zum Laptop, zu dem Modell, was Tim hat. Sollte es da nicht auch so eine Auflistung geben, welches was ist?
Na bei der 79 Evo müsste ja genau stehen, was die für eine Kodierung hat. Aber hier guckt doch, da ist doch schon PCIe, NVMe, SSD ist M-Key. Aber PCIe, Express, AHCI, SSD ist auch M-Key. Das verstehe ich nicht so ganz.
Na, auf jeden Fall brauchst du M. Hab ich das richtig verstanden, aber hat die auch irgendwie M auf beiden und auf dem einen noch irgendwie B oder so? Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ja, aber dann passt es ja schon nicht, deswegen hat er ja zwei davon.
Wir werden das rausfinden und berichten.
Ich habe mir mal so eine Kombination bestellt. High Point 7101A heißt der Quad-Adapter.
High mit Hi-Point oder High mit Hi-Gh? Mit G-H.
Zusammengeschrieben. 71 01 A. Genau, da guck dir jetzt mal den Preis an. Die kostet 458 Euro. Ist aber auch mit Lüfter, damit die vier Karten, die du da rein packst, weil die werden auch tatsächlich warm, wenn du die natürlich voll beballerst. Und jemand, der sich so eine Karte hier kauft, mit vierfach, der will das natürlich auch voll beballern. Da muss halt auch ein bisschen kühlen und so. Und weil da eben noch ein Chip drauf ist, der den PCI-Lane in vier aufteilt, kostet der halt ein bisschen was. Und weil es so ein Nischenprodukt ist, kostet er gleich mal noch ein bisschen viel mehr. Aber dann hast du tatsächlich... Was geben die an, wie viel er schafft? Steht da 25,6 Gigabyte? Nee, was steht da? Ja, das ist ja 32 Gigabyte die Sekunde. Könnte er theoretisch, ne?
Naja, wir werden da sicherlich noch ein paar gute Tipps bekommen. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es auch so zwei Ports irgendwie, Dinger gibt. Vielleicht nehme ich auch erst mal ein Port, haue mir da einfach zwei Terabyte rein. Aber das ist mal ein signifikantes Upgrade.
Auf jeden Fall, vor allem davon booten können.
Genau, ich habe jetzt eh gerade wieder einen Slot frei, dann kann ich den mal benutzen. Und dann hat man ja gleich wieder diese alten CD-ROM-Dinger.
Die Anschlüsse für die CD-ROM-Module, meintst du?
Die benutze ich nicht mehr.
Die sind ja nur SATA 2, die sind nicht so flott.
Ja, ich habe ja auch schon die SATA 3. Ich habe die Karte ja schon auf so einem, da ist ja einiges drauf, die lasse ich da auch drin, weil die ist ja jetzt nicht schlecht, aber die ist dann halt für andere Zwecke. Und dann hätte man halt so einen Teil, wo man irgendwie mal durchbuden kann. Und die 2TB Evo ist ja echt ganz schön günstig, muss ich sagen.
Aber sag mal nochmal, die Pro gab es nicht als 2TB oder wie?
Nee, die gibt es nur in 1TB. Aber so 2TB hier so 440 Euro, kann man mal machen. Das ist schon so ein bisschen so geblendet.
Da sind auch so eine Karten drin.
Das ist echt furchtbar, ich glaube, die 1TB von der Transcend für dieses Notebook kostet 600.
Ja, weil das andere Keying für die Samsung passen bei dir nicht.
Du brauchst halt diese speziellen. Ein Hörer hat auch schon gesagt, er hat diesen Adapter versucht für das MacBook und das hat nicht gut funktioniert.
Aber du willst wahrscheinlich 1TB haben, richtig?
Nee, ich lieb euch jetzt so ein bisschen, vielleicht doch erstmal nur 512.
Weil ich glaube, wenn ich das da habe, dann ist bei mir, ich hab genau eben so ein altes Apple-Modul in meinem Mac Pro drin mit so einem komischen Adapter. Das ist ein original Apple-SSD auch. Dann ist das vielleicht genau das King, was du brauchst. So, für jedenfalls dazu, also unerwartet, Apple baut für neun Jahre alte Rechner, baut nicht nur neue Firmen, damit ihr APFS funktioniert, nein. Sie schmeißen sogar NVMe-Support rein, plötzlich und unerwartet. Also in dem Forum sind alle ausgetickt und verstehen die Welt nicht mehr und sind alle voll happy.
Ich auch! Ich flippe auch voll aus. Flipp, flipp. Was ist denn hier mit diesen Webseiten? Hier kann man wieder nix bestellen. Soll ich dann mein ganzes Geld loswerden, wenn diese Webseiten hier so schwierig sind? So.
23,64 Euro, 22 Cent zu viel. Ja, das wär das aus der Mac Pro-Ecke.
Hier heißt es, Samsung EVO hält allerdings laut Smart nicht lange.
Na ja, komm, drauf an, was du damit machst.
Also ich hab jetzt auch eine EVO seit Jahren da drin.
Na wenn der täglich seine 4K-Movies da hin und her kopiert, dann kann sein, dass das Ding irgendwann in die Knie geht.
Aber das wird schon ein paar Jahre halten.
Aber wenn du da so wie so zwei Terabyte holst, dann verteilt sich das ja sowieso, dann hast du eh eine ganze Menge.
Ja, also ich würde sagen für so Desktop-Anwendungen mit Bluetooth davon und dann wird da mal so ein bisschen rumgeschrieben und mal ein paar neue Files angelegt, das ist normale Nutzung. Wenn du wirklich Serverbedarf hast und da wird permanent der Datenbestand hin und her gerödelt, dann ist es wichtig, solche Ausfall-Dinger zu haben. Aber ich denke, die beiden Angebote sind an sich schon ziemlich sinnvoll. Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt. Weil das kann man sich ja jetzt auch gleich mal reinbauen und sobald dann irgendwie neue Firmware offiziell ist, also die Firmware ist ja...
Genau, einbauen kannst du es vorher schon, weil nachdem du gebootet hast, siehst du das ja und kannst es benutzen, nur booten kannst du nicht davon. Wenn dann das Firmware-Update kommt, dann kannst du auch davon booten und ich berichte dir, wenn es...
Du hast das jetzt schon selber ausprobiert oder?
Nee, noch nicht, aber ich habe die Nachricht gelesen und gleich sofort klick, klick, klick. Die Samsung kommt Freitag, das Lykon-Modul kommt Montag. Aber ich habe noch ein anderes Lykon-Modul, dann nehme ich das so lange und dann teste ich das. Also Freitag werde ich das wissen.
Cool, das ist doch mal... Der von diesem Story mitbekommen, dass die ganze Hardware bei Amazon und bei Apple und vielen anderen verwandt sein soll.
Ja, aber die haben die Story ja von vorne bis hinten auseinandergenommen. Bloomberg war das oder wie heißt die? Jetzt haben sie nochmal nachgeliefert, noch mit einer zweiten Story von irgendeinem Typen. Haut wohl auch alles irgendwie nicht so hin. Also wahrscheinlich werden jetzt die nächsten Tage wieder alle komplett auseinandergenommen. Was ich aber grundsätzlich gut finde, ist, dass die Leute jetzt auch so ein Verständnis entwickeln.
Kurz sagen, was da war. Also es gab die Meldung bei Bloomberg, dass angeblich die Mainboards, die von der Firma Supermicro hergestellt wird, für Server-Mainboards irgendwie einen Chip, das klingt schon so ein bisschen wie aus einem Science-Fiction-Film. Wo ist der Chip? Oh, jetzt hat er den Chip eingebaut.
So wie bei Runaway Spinnen ist Todes mit dem Magnum-Darsteller. Da war ja auch immer so dieser...
Bei Pi oder so, also der Chip, das ist immer so ein magisches Ding.
Aus welchem Jahrhundert ist das?
Ich muss auch immer an hier Dr. Who denken, die Cybermen, mit dem Ding sie im Ohr.
Jungspunde kennen wir ja tollen Filme nicht.
Ja und ihr alten Männer kennt weder Dr. Who nicht.
Natürlich kenne ich Dr. Who.
Dr. Who habe ich schon geguckt, da hat es sich noch gar nicht gegeben. Nee, habe ich nicht, aber hätte ich.
Hättest du gekonnt.
Genau. Das haben schon Leute geguckt, da hat es mich noch nicht gegeben.
Die neue Dr. Who-Staffel hat angefangen. Echt?
Ja.
Auf Netflix?
Nein.
Die mit der Lady? Ja.
Ich hab noch nicht gucken können.
Geil.
Ja.
Die hat ja auch eine Folge bei Black Mirror gemacht, die Frau.
Die Frau hat die.
Jodie Whittaker. Ich kann mir den Namen merken. Das ist, ich weiß nicht wieso, aber.
Der ist großartig gespielt. Ich hab den noch an irgendeinem anderen Film auch gesehen.
Die trauen gerade dein Thema, du musst jetzt noch.
Entschuldigung, wo waren wir eigentlich?
Ist okay, ich hab die Jodie Whittaker neulich bei Cold Bear im Interview gesehen. War mal ein Thema eigentlich gerade. Ich hab's schon vergessen. Chips.
Ice-Corn große Chips, die die Welt übernehmen.
Ja, genau.
Apropos Chips.
Es macht auf jeden Fall schwer den Eindruck, dass an dieser Story nichts dran ist und es wird auch schon kooperiert, dass die Story sozusagen von den Amerikanern, von den Geheimdiensten oder von dem Außenministerium gelauncht wurde, um sozusagen China in Verruf zu bringen. Scheint ja auch geklappt zu haben. Also kurz danach, nach diesem Bloomberg-Artikel, ist ja sicher der Aktienpreis von Supermicro mal eben halbiert.
Supermicro ist eine amerikanische Marke. Supermicro ist eine amerikanische Marke.
Eine amerikanische Marke, die aber in China bauen. Ich dachte Supermicro wäre ein chinesisches Unternehmen.
Ja, dachte ich auch immer. Ist aber tatsächlich nicht so.
Ähm, wir gucken mal. Taiwanese American, okay. Also taiwanesisch, okay. Headquarter in Silicon Valley. Nachlesen hilft. So oder so. Gab's aber schon vor ein paar Jahren, da erinnere ich mich noch dran, also das ist ja nicht so, dass Apple jetzt gerade aufgehört hätte, Supermicro einzusetzen, sondern die haben ja vor ein paar Jahren schon mal alles abgekündigt. So von heute auf morgen. Und ich erinnere mich noch dran, als die Nachricht kam, ich glaube, das haben wir auch hier in der Freak Show behandelt. Kannst du dich da auch dran erinnern? Und da hatten wir doch schon, da war doch schon dieses Gerücht in der Welt, dass sie das getan haben, weil sie der Hardware nicht vertrauen.
Haben sie auch so gesagt, glaube ich, dass es da irgendwie Security-Issues gibt.
Ich hab das nicht mehr so gut im Kopf. Das Ding ist, diese Story macht sich jetzt an diesem Chip fest. Und das ist insofern ein bisschen abenteuerlich, als dass sie ja ihre Quellen nicht nennen, was jetzt erstmal nicht verwunderlich ist. Außer einer, da haben sie nämlich so einen Hardware-Nerd, der auf der BlackHat immer so Vorträge gehalten hat. Genau, diesen Joe Fitzpatrick, den haben sie ja irgendwie befragt. Und der hat den halt so eher so generell geantwortet. So, ja, könnte man, geht, hab ich mal gezeigt.
Das kennen wir so ein bisschen von der Presse hier, so in Deutschland. Die machen das auch immer so. Die fragen ein, was so gehen würde. Und dann liest du den Artikel, dann steht da ja, so wurde es gemacht.
Genau. Und ich hab mir nämlich jetzt im Risky Business, in diesem Security-Podcast, ein kurzes Interview mit ihm, darüber, wie er sich da in der Befragung verhalten hätte. Da meinte er so, naja, was ihm halt echt ein bisschen fishy vorkam, als der Blueback-Typ hätte ihn halt irgendwie gefragt, naja, hier ist von dieser Art Chips die Rede. Und da war so von Kaplern die Rede, also so, was ist die richtige, Übertragern. Und das sind so Bausteine, die man halt zum Beispiel einsetzt bei Wi-Fi-Karten, Internet-Karten, also die so bei Transzifern quasi zum Einsatz kommen, um so die Signalqualität zu erhöhen. Und da kam so eine Nachfrage, was denn damit sei. Und dann hatte er halt von den ein Millionen Varianten, die du heutzutage so kaufen kannst, ein Bild von so einer Webseite quasi ihm geschickt, so nach dem Motto, ja, das ist sowas.
So ein ganz kleines Ding halt.
Ein kleines Bauteil, der irgendwie in dem Moment der Beschreibung entsprach, nachdem dieser Journalist gefragt hatte. Und dann war in dem Artikel genau dieses Bauteil, was er ihm geschickt hat. Das war dann sozusagen so in dem Artikel das, was sie da so gefeatured haben. Alles, alles, was da sozusagen an halbwegs belastbaren... Also, erstens sei das alles nicht belastbar. Und das, was dann sozusagen als Beispiele geliefert wird, das war halt alles so sehr auf Basis seiner theoretischen Beschreibung, was an sich ginge, dass er halt einfach dem ganzen Kram nicht glaubt. Und alle sind ja am... Letztendlich meinte er halt auch, naja, das Problem ist halt auch das, was sie da quasi als Hardware hinter Tür beschreiben, wäre am Ende alles mit Software sehr viel einfacher zu machen. Weil am Ende hilft dir die Hardware alleine halt auch nichts. Du musst ja trotzdem irgendwie Software mit reinbringen. Und ob dir dann dieser Chip da irgendwas hilft, schon gar nicht so ein komischer Übertrager, der auf dem Mainboard an der Stelle überhaupt nichts zu suchen hat und viel mehr auffallen würde als irgendwas anderes.
Kam da auch ein bisschen shady vor.
Genau. Trotz alledem, ich hab das halt auch noch so in Erinnerung, dass damals, zumindest wir so darüber gesprochen haben, dass Apple so ein Super-Macro rausgeschmissen hat und was weiß ich, wo sie jetzt das irgendwie herholt.
Aber ich glaub damals hatten wir ja gedacht, weil es gibt ja diese Intel-Management-Engine in den CPUs. Also dieser verdeckte Bereich, an dem man irgendwie nicht so normal rankommt. Und dass es sich eher um sowas irgendwie handelt, dass auch die da per BIOS oder per sonst wo da irgendwie noch was drin haben, aber nicht, dass da Exportchips mit reinkommen.
Supervisern. Ja, auf jeden Fall türkische Geschichte. Ich wüsste ja gerne, was Apple jetzt eigentlich wirklich in ihren Servern hat und Amazon. Also was bauen die da wirklich in ihren Servern an?
Vielleicht groß die jetzt nform E-Booten. Keine Ahnung, weiß nicht.
Ich sag dir, das ist alles schon mit Arm-Servern voll. Die bauen das alles schon selber. Läuft alles auf A12.
Vielleicht.
Da testen sie nämlich die künftigen Prozessoren für ihre Mac Pro. Ich sag dir, die bringen nächstes Jahr diesen Mac Pro raus. Alles voll mit Arm. Da haben wir hier schon seit drei Jahren bei uns in der iCloud laufen.
Vielleicht bringen sie ja weiterhin mit Intel raus, aber dann mit lauter Arm-Comput-Engines oder so.
Was soll das sein?
Computer, die halt dann die schweren Aufgaben lösen müssen, also die schwere Arbeit machen dann die kleinen Arms in Masse.
Schwere Arbeit? Na ja, die Arbeit können die genauso machen. Die Frage ist halt nur, was ist stromspannender? Und am Ende ist es halt stromspannender. Und für diese ganze Diskussion mit wieviel Thermal-Headroom haben wir denn da eigentlich? Na ja, egal. Das ist alles so ein bisschen Zukunftsmittel. Auf jeden Fall wird ordentlich gehackt, aber wohl eher in Software als in Hardware.
Und am Artikel anscheinend wurde eine Menge gehackt, weil da stimmt ja auch nicht irgendwie alles, glaube ich, oder nichts. Aber das wird sich die nächsten Tage aufdröseln. Aber ich finde gut, dass jetzt das so ein bisschen auch mal Thema ist, dass man auch Hardware manipulieren könnte, wenn man wollte und so weiter. Weil möglichst ist es schon, so wie der Fitzpatrick's halt gesagt hat, nur dass so, wie die das erzählen, ohne Beispiele zu nennen, nicht so richtig passt. So, jetzt noch ein kurzer, was ich eigentlich wollen machen wollte, kurze Bemerkung zum Intro zu The Sequence. Ja, das ist mir wichtig. Ich bin da nämlich schwer am Zocken und ich muss jetzt kurz mal meinen Punktestand rausrücken, weil es ist wirklich schwer. Und ich muss jetzt mal stolz berichten, dass ich inzwischen 751 Punkte habe und damit auf Platz 199 liege. Und die Leute sollen sich mal anstrengen. Also mir macht es mega Spaß und es ist wirklich ziemlich schwer. Man kann danach bei dem Spiel immer schön beobachten, wenn du geistig nicht ganz fit bist, dann löst du diese Rätsel auch nicht. Wenn du dich zu lange auf ein Problem stürzt, dann löst du es auch nicht. Wenn du dann mal zwei, drei Tage nichts machst und das dann frisch mit leerem Hirn anguckst, dann geht es auch wieder. Also man kann richtig merken, wie man sich überfordert, wie man wieder frisch ist und so weiter und so fort.
Dazu brauche ich aber kein Spiel. Da muss ich nur meine Code-Quality oder meine Näh-Quality mir angucken.
Du meinst dann, dass der Faden macht so ein bisschen Schlangenlinien?
Nee, aber ich merke, egal ob ich code, oder auch nähe oder was auch immer mache, wenn ich unkonzentriert bin, unfokussiert bin, mache ich kleine Fehlerchen. Die mir dann halt nicht auf...
Code habe ich nicht, so komplizierte Stellen, wo ich so lange auf ein so kleines Bild gucke.
Anders gesagt, wenn du dir was Neues aneignest, also dann merke ich das auch. Auf jeden Fall. Ich habe deswegen auch eine Projektliste, die ich so ein bisschen ordne, was als nächstes zu tun ist, was ich so abends brain dead im Bett noch erledigen kann, weil es irgendwie so ein bisschen mindless ist.
Genau, mal so Jobs hier. Das muss ich nur mal schnell runterhaken. Das ist easy. Das hier muss ich komplett was neu implementieren. Das mache ich mal morgen, wenn der Kaffee frisch war und ich gerade auch frisch bin. Morgens ist nach dem Aufstehen.
Ich sag's ja nur so im Vergleich. Wir haben andere Morgende.
Aber da fällt mir wieder ein, das nervt mich total, dass hier Apple im App Store diese Wishlist rausgeschmissen hat, weil ich mir nämlich das Spiel speichern wollte.
Die haben eine Wishlist?
Die hat mal eine, bilde ich mir jedenfalls ein.
Echt?
Dass man sich eben zu Sachen merken konnte und sie sich dann später kaufen konnte. Ihr guckt mich gerade an, als würde ich von einer komplett völlig anderen Welt reden.
App Store.
Ja, gab es das nicht?
Let die Zweifel selber jetzt. Gab es noch nie, kommt jetzt gleich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, dass es da eine Wishlist gegeben hätte. Also bei Amazon gibt es eine, aber bei Apple, für die Apps.
Naja, ich meine, du willst dir ja meistens Sachen noch mal genauer anschauen, bevor du sie dir kaufst, oder?
Was es gab in letzter Zeit, ist, dass Apple, und zwar das ist handprogrammiert nur für bestimmte Apps, hatten die mal so ein Jahr kommt in ein paar Monaten raus, notify me, wenn es irgendwie fertig ist. Das haben die aber von Hand in ihren Store programmiert. Das haben nur ganz bestimmte Apps, die sie auf der Keynote vorstellen oder so, wo man sich dann vorberichtigen kann. Bei diesem Mario-Spiel war das zum Beispiel so, glaube ich. Na hier, Mario Brothers, gab es da nicht so ein Spiel auf dem IOS irgendwie? Das gab es auch mit so einer Vorankündigung, wo man schon sagen könnte, man hätte es gerne, wenn es rauskommt. Das war so ein Spezialding, das gab es für alle anderen App-Submitters, da gab es dieses Feature nicht.
Der Shed gibt mir auf jeden Fall recht, es gab mal eine Wishlist.
Ja, und die gibt es nicht mehr?
Nee. iTunes-Appstore, okay. iTunes, wer benutzt das denn?
Die iTunes, naja, das ist meine Appstore. Achso, ich bin jetzt hier gerade auf dem Mac-Appstore. Haben sie das vielleicht mit dem Redesign des Apptos gekillt?
Ja, es ist an den Tisch gefallen beim Aufräumen.
Wie, man soll sich jetzt eine andere Wishlist-App holen?
Ich würde mal sagen, ich habe meinen Punkt drüber gemacht, mit dem Spiel, ich hole jetzt mal das Eis.
Ah, gut die Idee.
Liegt der mal jetzt noch vom letzten Mal?
Ich habe auf jeden Fall Neues besorgt, für uns alle, wenn ihr was haben wollt. Also es gibt für jeden Eis.
Ja, wenn schon Freak Show, Eis und Service. Hagen, das hat in Japan total viele coole Special-Sonder-Edition-Eis-Versionen. Aber die gibt es dafür nur in ganz kleinen Bechern. Da würde Dennis wahrscheinlich nicht glücklich werden. Aber sehr lecker.
Ohje. Ich hab noch ein Fundstück. Ich glaube, über GitHub hab ich das natürlich gefunden. Und zwar hab ich letztens überlegt, ich wollte in dem Projekt, das ich gerade habe, nicht unbedingt so was wie PIVIC einbauen, um so Tracking zu haben, um so zu wissen, wie viele User so auf der Webseite herumflattern. Und hab mal geschaut, was es so gibt, um die ganzen Access Logs auf dem Server auszulesen, um da so einfach mal zu schauen. Also manchmal reicht ja einfach nur so die Anzahl der Leute, vielleicht so die Uhrzeit und Wenn, aber das weiß kein Moos, von wo sie so gekommen sind. Und da gibt es ein wunderbares Tool, das heißt Go Access. Und Tim wird gerade mal den Link in den Chat reinwerfen. Das kann man auf der Command Line, auf der Konsole laufen lassen. Oder aber man kann sich jetzt sowas wie so ein HTML-Report rausrendern lassen, was irgendwie auch ganz nice ist, um es mal so irgendwie anderen Leuten zu zeigen. Man kann sich alle Daten halt auch als Jason irgendwie rausnehmen. Das hab ich jetzt nicht probiert, weil ich wollte wirklich nur was mal, um schnell zu schauen, alle Logfiles durchgehen. Was so passiert ist auf dem Server seit so einem Release. Und fand das halt echt ganz geil, weil ja, es wird gerade im Chat auch auf das nicht PIVX, sondern Matomo hingewiesen. Aber da ich halt zum Beispiel auch sowas wie Analyzer blocke bei mir, dass ich das Tracking halt nicht haben will, wird sowas ja auch bei vielen einfach weggeblockt. Deswegen wollte ich einfach mal so schauen, ohne wieder irgendwie andere Software direkt jetzt in den Projekt mit zu integrieren, was es da noch so gibt, dass man einfach nur mal kurz in die Logs reinschaut. Und dieses Go Access ist auf jeden Fall ein schnuffeliges kleines Tool, was man entweder reportingmäßig sich anschauen kann oder einfach nur mal auf dem Terminal öffnet, um so zu sehen, was so die Leute, also was wie viele Leute jetzt so in der letzten Zeit auf dem, auf der Seite rumgeschwört sind. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ganz geil und man sieht natürlich halt auch so die ganzen Crawler, die versuchen nach einer WordPress Bullshit Exit zu suchen, Bullshit Setup zu suchen, wo ich mir dachte, ja, genau, dass ich dann halt so die ganzen Crawler immer mal vorbeikomme. Aber ja, genau, also Go Access ist auf jeden Fall mal einen Blick wert, wenn man seine Serverlogs mal unter die Lupe nehmen möchte.
Was willst du denn da sehen?
Also mich hat primär wirklich nur interessiert, so eigentlich die Anzahl der Nutzer. Also wir hatten einen Release irgendwie in einem Job, wo ich gerade bin. Und die Frage war eigentlich nur so, wie viele Leute schauen sich sowas an? Und es ging halt wirklich eigentlich nur um die Anzahl der Leute und gegebenenfalls noch sowas wie Referrer. Und das hat das Tool halt abgedeckt. Und ohne dass man eben so einen PIVX, Entschuldigung, Matomo, ich vergesse den Namen halt immer wieder.
Wieso was das ist mit diesem, heißt das jetzt nicht mehr so?
Nee, das heißt nicht mehr so. Die haben sich umbenannt.
Ach, warum denn?
Da haben sie sich bestimmt wieder gestritten, oder? Code of Conduct verletzt. Nee, weiß ich in der Tat nicht. Weiß nicht, ob es vielleicht auch namensrechtlich irgendwas gab. Ja, die heißen jetzt halt anders.
Pivik ist Naomatomo. Blablabla.
Why we are changing from Pivik. Ja, also sie haben sich umbenannt halt.
Ich guck grad mal warum.
Bisschen komischen Namen aget, aber in letzter Zeit auch ein bisschen aus, oder?
Das heißt bestimmt irgendwas ganz Tolles. Blühende Blume, die niemals verwelkt. Nein, also ich wollte das jetzt nicht direkt auf dem Server, weil dann wäre wieder mit bei der IT-Anfragen, weil das irgendwie zentral bei uns über die IT laufen müsste. Und dann gibt es ja noch sowas, das nennt sich dann halt GDPR, wo halt dann in der Uni nochmal wieder andere bürokratische Höhen gegebenenfalls auftauchen würden. Also das war dann halt alles so ein bisschen unklar. Und nur um zu wissen, sowas wie die Anzahl, uns hat eigentlich auch weniger interessiert jetzt, wo die Leute wirklich herkommen, geografisch und so weiter, habe ich jetzt einfach nur mal geschaut, was es gibt, um sich die Server-Logs auszuwerten. Die hat man halt eh da drauf, die Access-Logs. Und da war das irgendwie erstmal so das Tool, wo ich gesagt habe, ok, passt, ohne irgendwie schon wieder etwas Größeres installieren zu müssen.
Man kann ja abspielen, wie Matomo richtig ausgesprochen wird.
Na dann.
Anhören. Matomo oder Matomo?
Matomo klingt Japanisch.
Das eine ist höflich, das andere ist unhöflich ausgesprochen.
Ja, also es heißt auf Japanisch angeblich Honesty. Aufrichtig. Das scheint jetzt überhaupt das Ding zu sein, um überhaupt noch irgendwie freie Domains zu finden. Dann guckt ihr jetzt einfach was coole Namen auf Japanisch heißen und benutzt sie dann in latanischer Schreibweise. Und wenn latanisch durch ist, dann... Genau. Und erst Emoji, Romange, was kommt noch alles. Und wenn Japanisch durchgespielt ist, was gibt es dann?
Nee, dann kommt alles nur noch in Emojis, aneinander Kettung. Ich finde, das ist so eine Unterart, diese Emojis überall. In so Pull-Requests und auf Webseiten, so dieses... Get in touch! Und dann hast du diese wedelnden Hand, und du denkst dir so, wat? Ich nehm die Leute dann irgendwie nicht mehr so ernst.
Oder als Variabel in der Pyramid-Sprache.
Manche unterstützen ja schon. Mir ist gerade wieder eingefallen...
Das Kackehäufeln ist dann für besonders schlechten Code?
Ja, Code Smell kennst du nicht? Nein. Mir ist gerade wieder eingefallen, die Japaner übernehmen halt relativ viel aus anderen Sprachen an Wörtern. Und es gibt einen im Japanischen geläufigen medizinischen Fachbegriff, nämlich Gegenhalten. Die sagen wirklich dann Gegenhalten.
Wofür?
Im Prinzip, wenn du halt wirklich Reflexe testest. Also Patient soll quasi gegen deine Hand drücken. Und dieser Vorgang wird im japanischen Medizinfachkreis als Gegenhalten bezeichnet, weil du hältst halt gegen. Das ist das deutsche Wort? Ja, die benutzen das deutsche Wort. Und die wussten halt auch nicht, was es direkt heißt. Und ich wurde dann gefragt, was heißt eigentlich Gegenhalten? Aber es gibt generell sehr, sehr niedliche japanische Begriffe. Zum Beispiel wurde bei uns bei den Untersuchungen, ich bin jetzt etwas abgedriftet, aber egal, Pachi Pachi Pachi und Tom Tom Tom sind japanische Wörter zur Beschreibung von in dem Fall Bewegungen. Pachi Pachi Pachi ist halt bitte Fingerspitzen aufeinander tappen. Pachi Pachi Pachi und Tom Tom Tom ist Fuß auf den Boden stampfen. Pachi Pachi Pachi.
Hätten wir nur wieder Motipalzen ein. Wenn ich sagen würde, du hast ein schönes Körper, würdest du es gegen mich halten? Das ist ein großartiges Sketch mit den Ungarn, wo so ein Typ dafür verurteilt wird, weil er irgendwie ein Wörterbuch rausgebracht hat mit falschen Übersetzungen. Wo sozusagen so normale Fragen wie wo geht's denn hier zum Bahnhof dann mit irgendeinem Schweingraben übersetzt wurde. Das geht ja auch nicht.
Mir wird nur ständig, ach du machst was mit Ganganalyse. Hier, kennst du den Monty Python Sketch Ministry of Funny Walks oder wie es heißt?
Mein Luftgieß in Fahrzeug ist voller Arle.
Das kenn ich, hab ich mal gehört.
Ja, das ist doch alles derselbe.
Entschuldigung.
Alle essen Eis.
Ich möchte diesen Teppich nicht kaufen, er ist sehr kratzt. Das könnt ihr nicht, das könnt ihr mir nicht antun. Mein Gott, ich muss irgendwann mal so einen Seniorenpodcast machen.
Ihr zwei seid der Seniorenpodcast, um das mal kurz.
Wir drücken den Altersdurchschnitt.
Wir haben da ja noch so ein paar medizinisch angehauchtere Themen.
Ach wirklich? Das hatten wir ja noch gar nicht heute.
Ich hab schon so viel geredet. Mein Wortcount ist aufgebraucht. Ich rede nicht so viel.
Ja, du weißt, dass ich auch sonst nicht so viel rede, aber hier muss man viel reden.
Habt ihr gehört, dass MS-DOS jetzt open source ist?
Jo, schon gesehen auf GitHub.
Free Software sozusagen.
Aber nur zu Anschauungszwecken, man soll keine Pull-Request stellen.
Wieso würde sich dann die Geschichte ändern, wenn wir jetzt ein Pull-Request senden?
Nee, sie würden ihn nicht annehmen. Der ist sozusagen closed. Also man soll forken und dann soll man da rum basteln. Ist sozusagen nur für dokumentarische Zwecke. Finde ich aber trotzdem gut.
Sie lösen damit auch ein paar andere Probleme. Weil es gibt einfach noch erstaunlich viele Systeme da draußen.
Die noch updaten müssen, die was?
Ja, die einfach auf MS-DOS laufen.
Ich weiß, es ist auch...
Das ist Industriestandard.
Aber wenn sie keine Pull-Request annehmen, dann gibt es doch auch keine...
Nee, aber es löst halt sozusagen diese ganze Lizenzproblematik. Und macht natürlich potenziell jetzt den Weg auch auf für einen Fix-DOS. Also da wird es so viele altbackene Hacker geben, die sich jetzt auf diesen Kram ihrer Kindheit stürzen. Ja, und auch wenn es Teil meiner Kindheit war, ich werde mich da auf jeden Fall nicht drauf stürzen, aber ich kann mir sehr gut ausmalen, dass es da eine Menge Leute gibt, die sagen so, oh geil, jetzt kann ich mir mal den Code anschauen mit dem Kram, mit dem ich mich irgendwie ein Leben lang rumgeschlagen habe.
Ich hätte irgendwie auch Lust, mir das mal anzugucken.
Ja. Jetzt irritierst du mich.
Du hast keine Zeit für sowas.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Also es ist, wie ich es richtig erinnere, es ist DOS 1.1. und 2.0. Auch nur was herausgehauen hat.
1.2.5.
Auf GitHub.
Ok, also DOS 2.0 war, ich weiß nicht, ob es das einzige Feature war, aber mit MS-DOS 2.0 gab es dann Directories im Fallsystem. Das war dann sozusagen das große Ding bei DOS 2.0.
Apple freut sich über die sich verändernden Backgrounds ja gerade im aktuellen Mojave.
Ja, zu Recht. Das redet mir jetzt mal nicht schlecht.
Nein, wir sind auf einer Linie mit den Ordnern.
Ja, es war auf jeden Fall schon immer irgendwie das Unix für Arme und dass es auch ganz gutes Wege ist. Aber es hilft sicherlich einigen Leuten da draußen, dass das jetzt sozusagen so verfügbar ist, weil damit ist es ja dann auch distributierbar, installierbar usw. Und was weiß ich, wie viele Ölbohrplattformen jetzt weiter arbeiten können. Irgendwie die Software-Frage gelöst.
Ich glaube bei meinem Honda-Händler war vor zwei Jahren deren Ersatzteil und Duco nicht, aber Ersatzteil und Bestellungs- und sonstiges System war ein DOS-Programm. Also inzwischen haben die jetzt da auch Web und Zeug und alles. Also vor zwei Jahren noch glaube ich war das alles so DOS-Zeugs, wo die da hin und her gesprungen sind und wo sie jeden Tastendruck sozusagen schon auswendig hatten, wie sie da schnell sich hin und her manövrieren können. Immer noch.
Ihr spricht ja auch was dafür, um mal eine Lanze zu brechen, weil diese Systeme mögen zwar beschränkt gewesen sein und so weiter, aber sie waren halt auch in bestimmter Hinsicht vollständig verstanden.
Sie wurden nicht verstanden, sondern es wurde gewusst, wie man sie bedient. Genau, eine Krankenschwester zum Beispiel weiß nicht, was dahinter steht, sondern sie weiß, sie muss jetzt die Tasse drücken und die Tasse drücken. Und dann ist sie in dem Feld und gibt exakt den Wert ein. Das ist was anderes, als sie haben das System verstanden.
Naja, was ich damit meine ist, alle Fehler, die da so auftauchen können, sind alle schon mal aufgetreten. So und irgendwo gibt es dann auch nicht mehr Code und mehr Fehlermöglichkeiten. Man hat das sozusagen alles im Griff. Das ändert sich auch nicht so groß.
Genau, wenn jetzt der Fehler auftritt, muss ich die Tasse drücken, damit kommt dann der Fehler und dann drücke ich die Tasse und dann ist alles gut.
Ich rede jetzt mehr von so Betriebssystemebenen. Also man weiß in etwa, was alles schiefgehen kann und im Rahmen dessen, wie die Systeme benutzt werden, ist es sozusagen contained. Während halt heutzutage die Betriebssysteme mit jedem Update am permanent anderes Verhalten in einer Myriade von Verästelungen, von Nutzungsoptionen an den Tag legen, die sich dann wiederum mit dem Verhalten anderer Systeme beißen und das Ganze dann noch im Netzwerk und permanent schaffst du neue Fehlerkulturen und neue Fehlerkonstellationen. Und da sind dann irgendwie diese kleinen abgeschlossenen Systeme mit ihrem MS-DOS irgendwie auch ganz gut dran, weil sie halt irgendwie wissen, okay, das ist jetzt genau das und mehr ist es nicht. Und jemand freut sich da. Aber es war nicht schön mit DOS damals. Also ich hatte wirklich nur so eine kurze Phase, wo ich mir das angeschaut habe. Ich glaube, als ich damals, als ich angefangen habe, mal Geld zu verdienen mit programmieren, das gab es mal, habe ich tatsächlich Code geschrieben auf einem... Gott, wie ist denn das Wort nochmal? Wie ist denn nochmal der fucking Vorgänger? Jetzt fällt mir das nie ein. Das alte Mikrocomputerbetriebssystem...
C-80, Röppler-Chat?
Wieso gibt's da CPM? Kein... CPM war doch CPM, oder? Ich war ganz durcheinander hier.
In einem Land vor unserer Zeit.
CPM-System. Das waren so... Was so vor MS-DOS auf so frühen Computern so lief, das war extrem beschränkt. So Intel 8080, Z80-Kram. Das war wirklich gnadenlos. Allein um da eine Datei zu kopieren, musste man da Klimmzüge machen. Das war nicht mehr schön. Da war DOS dann im Prinzip auch ein großer Schritt nach vorne. Kein Wunder, dass sich darauf alle ganz gut einigen konnten. Furchtbar war das auf jeden Fall.
Konnte der 128er nicht auch CPM, wenn er wollte? Hat aber niemand benutzt, ne?
Es gab dafür so eine CPM-Erweiterung, glaube ich, für diesen C128. Genau, irgendwie sowas Merkwürdiges. Ich wusste nicht so richtig, warum sie das überhaupt rausgebracht haben, wer das brauchte, aber ich kann mich auch nicht erinnern, dass das einen nennenswerten Erfolg hatte oder eine Bedeutung für dieses System. Wo habe ich denn das jetzt eigentlich gerade erzählt?
Du meinst, dass DOS-Programmierung ist ganz, ganz schlimm?
Ach so, naja, okay, ich wollte einfach nur so ein bisschen meine...
Dein erstes Geld verdienen war immer das DOS-Programm.
Genau, mein erstes Geld verdienen, ich habe dann tatsächlich so Kassensysteme irgendwie auf so einem skurrilen... mit Hilfe eines solchen skurrilen CPM-Systems gemacht. Und dann lief der Code aber letzten Endes auf so einer dedicated Hardware. Das war quasi so ein Embedded-System. So ein frühes Embedded-System. Das war im Prinzip nur so ein kleiner Mikrocontroller, der so ein paar Tasten machen konnte und Barcode. Und das war dann so die erste mobile Datenerfassung. Das war jetzt, sagen wir mal, so für 1984 war das schon ziemlich advanced. Ähm, so, aber... Nicht 84, Entschuldigung, 89 war das ziemlich advanced. Im Prinzip der Vorläufer aller mobilen Datenerfassungssysteme. So die Zeit war das halt. Ich fand das schon immer irgendwie merkwürdig, diese DOS-Welt. Und als dann irgendwie diese PCs kamen und so Verbreitungen gefunden haben, und ich mir dachte so, okay, ich guck's jetzt mal an. Dann hatte ich halt so einen PC-Klon, so einen Commodore PC-10. Das war so dieser erste richtig populäre PC-Klon, also der nicht von IBM war. Ich fühlte mich da auf jeden Fall nicht wohl. Und ich fühlte mich auch mit diesem Atari dann, den ich dann später hatte, nicht wohl. Der nämlich im Prinzip auch nichts anderes war, als so eine Kopie von diesem alten DOS-Scheiß nur mit dem 68.000 Prozessor. Also auch irgendwie merkwürdig. Das hieß dann ja sogar TOS, dieses System.
Tremille Operating System.
Genau. Benannt nach dem Chef...
Tremille.
Jack Tremille, diesem verrückten Texaner. Also ein lustiger kleiner, dicker Kauz. Jack Tremille, der war damals relativ bekannt. Also ich will ihn jetzt nicht mit Steve Jobs vergleichen, aber er war, sagen wir mal so, einer von diesen Bossen von den populären Firmen. Und Commodore war ja nun definitiv einer der populäreren Unternehmen. Und er hat dann halt irgendwie auf dem Atari dieses Tremille Operating System gemacht. Warum ist er ein ganz lustiger Typ? Ich hab den mal kennengelernt und er lachte viel.
Ich muss jetzt auch noch kurz eine Geschichte erzählen, weil fehl mir gerade ein. Und zwar mein erster Job am Computer Geldverdienen war irgendwie Anfang der 90er. Und zwar war ich ja Assembler-Spezium. Mein erster Job war nicht, dass ich was programmieren sollte, sondern ich sollte was reverse-engineeren. Da bin ich zu so einem Typen nach Wedding gefahren. Und der hat mir dann irgendwie was erzählt von er muss hier wissen, wie das funktioniert und so weiter. Ich muss doch wissen, was das für eine CPU ist, sonst kann ich da ja nichts reverse-engineeren oder mir das Assembler angucken und so weiter. Und dann stellte sich langsam im Laufe des Gesprächs raus, dass es sich um Spielautomaten handelte. Der wollte also wissen, wie man die am besten bescheißen kann. Und ich hab mir das dann eine Weile erzählen lassen und so weiter, mich dann aber da zum Glück nicht mehr gemeldet. Aber der wollte, dass ich da rausfinde, wie der Zufall berechnet wird, der kein Zufall ist.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade bei dem alten Scheiß sind, können wir an dieser Stelle nochmal einen Termintipp geben für alle, die die Freak Show früh genug gehört haben. Nämlich an diesem Wochenende am 13. und 14. Oktober ist wieder mal das Vintage Computing Festival Berlin im Deutschen Technikmuseum.
Da war es schon letztes Jahr.
Also seit dem letzten Jahr...
Nicht mehr da in Mitte?
Nicht mehr da in Mitte.
War das HU?
Es kann sein, dass es zur HU gehört. Auf jeden Fall. Da ist jetzt nicht mehr, sondern das Deutschen Technikmuseum in diesem neuen Trakt, in diesem langen Teil, wo die neue Ausstellung ist. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool als Ausstellungsort. Und ja, da steht dann viel alter Kram rum. Ich hoffe, dass ich die Zeit finde, da noch mal ausführlich zu schauen und dass da auch noch mal diese ganzen Prozessorspezies da sind. Ich finde immer wieder, dass man da doch eine ganze Menge lernen kann aus diesem alten Kram. Es ist kostenloser Eintritt, geht dahin. Es ist wirklich sehr schön.
Und am Samstag gibt es wieder strange Chiptune-Party, was ich immer nicht so ganz verstehen kann. Das ist dann so mit so 8-Bit-Musik und so. So, genug alter Scheiß.
Tetris Over. Tetris Over.
Ach, Musik.
Kurze Anmerkung zur letzten Sendung. Mich hatte danach jemand auf Twitter gefragt. Also es ging um diese Die-Shots von dem MC681010. Und da ich manchmal ein bisschen faul bin, hab ich ihm nicht direkt geantwortet. Hab vorhin aber zwei verschiedene gepostet, weil ich noch sogar etwas größere gefunden habe. Das heißt, wenn er demnächst die Sendung sieht, dann muss er zur Not irgendwie mal in meinem Twitter gucken. Ich twitter nicht so viel, sollte noch relativ weit oben sein, wenn man mich da...
Können wir das einfach mal in die Show Notes nehmen?
Ja, ich hab ja dieses Slack nicht, da musst du das da...
Ja, ja, ja, ich bin schon unterwegs.
Genau.
Ah, hier. Zwei Stück, um was unterscheidet die beiden?
Der letztere ist der, den ich eigentlich hatte. Der ist irgendwie 17.000 x 19.000 Punkte groß. Der andere, den ich danach gefunden hab, ist irgendwie 25.000 x 25.000 Punkte groß. Der sollte eine noch bessere Auflösung haben. Und vor allem sind das zwei verschiedene Maskenrevisionen. Das heißt, wenn einer richtig lange Weile hat, dann kann er sich da noch reinzoomen und kann ja die Unterschiede entdecken, was die Unterschiede zwischen diesen beiden Revisionen sind. Also das eine ist RG20 und das andere war RC97 oder 997RC oder irgendwie so, keine Ahnung. Es gab früher immer so Maskenrevisionen, die dann so mit, weil die Chips irgendwie noch Fehler hatten. Und dann, es war genau beschrieben, welcher was wo wie hatte. siliconpron.org Und die Lette muss mir dann sagen, wo hier ihr Copyshop ist, ob der sowas drucken kann, in groß. Ich hab gehört, hier du hast hier einen Copyshop um die Ecke. Hat der bis 12 offen?
Zu spät, zu spät. Da kann man sich dann auf jeden Fall schönes Poster draus machen.
Die Frage ist, ob wir das... Das ist mein Plan.
Aber 6810 ist ja sehr...
Na, weil das der 68000er ohne Fehler ist eigentlich. Na, der 68000er hatte einen Fehler, nämlich der hatte einen Command, hätte privileged sein sollen. Und das war er aber nicht. Und das haben sie mit dem 6810 gefixt, weil erst mit dem 6810 kannst du so Zeug wie Virtual Memory und so Sachen machen, dass du das für Unix einsetzen kannst. Mit dem 68000er ging das nicht, weil du da den Supervisor-Mode einfach so hättest einschalten können oder irgendwie so. Mit dem 6810 war das halt ein privileged Command und dann ging das nicht mehr. Und das Zweite ist, dass der 68000er bei einem Clear in Memory hat er erst gelesen und dann geklärt, was unnötig ist. Und bei den Custom Chips von Amiga sogar, da hat ein Read auch schon was ausgelöst. Nicht nur das Schreiben, sondern das Read auch schon. Und das war nicht so gut. Und in der 6810, wenn der cleart, dann cleart er auch wirklich nur und least vorher nicht. Also das Performance-mäßig und auch so mäßig ist das.
Aber vom Layout sind die eigentlich gleich?
Komplett kompatibel. 68000er Serie halt, ja.
Okay, also der 6810 ist nicht ein anderer Prozessor, sondern es ist eigentlich derselbe in grün.
Also man konnte beim Amiga den 68000er rausnehmen und den 6810 reinstecken und dann lief das genauso wie vorher. War sogar minimal schneller. Sehr, sehr, sehr wenig, aber es war schneller. Und die Multiplikation und Division sind von 70 Tag Zyklen auf 40 runter oder irgendwie so. Also ich hab das damals gemacht, hab viel Geld in die Hand genommen und bin zu Computare gegangen irgendwo da im Town-Scene-Anfang oder wo das da war und hab mir für 180 D-Marken 6810 gekauft und den da reingestöpselt. Das ist einfach mein Lieblingsprozessor.
Pin-kompatibel und so weiter.
Pin-kompatibel, alles einfach reindrücken geht. Dein OS musste das natürlich unterscheiden und können. Aber sonst war der, ja, kompatibel.
Cool. Mal gucken, ob mein Preview abstürzt. Nee, geht sogar. Also, jetzt gucken wir uns den mal hier schön an. Ach, ist ja herrlich.
Dann zoom mal ran, das ist ja jetzt noch... Ich zu Hause auf meinem 4K-Fernseher wundere mich, weil ich immer noch ein paar Mal reinzoomen kann, obwohl mein Fernseher schon so eine riesen Auflösung hat. Und man kommt immer noch ein bisschen ran. Ist das jetzt Actual Size?
Ich weiß nicht, ob der das so groß drucken kann. Also in der Auflösung.
Ja, das hängt vom...
Copyshop kann doch schon 600 dB drucken oder so, oder?
Du kannst ja auch auf... Du kannst ja richtig groß machen.
Ich hab dir grad einen Link geschickt an.
Quadratmeter.
Es gibt nicht nur A0, sondern es gibt dann doppelt so groß, heißt 2A0 und das hätt ich gern.
Doppel A0? Also es gibt's hier bei dem Pinguin-Druck um die Ecke, aber die sind halt eher so für... Ich will halt 50 Poster davon haben und zahlst du dann irgendwie?
Nee, 50 Poster brauch ich jetzt nicht. Also ich dachte eigentlich an zwei, nämlich eins für mich, eins für den Club. Und was ich so online gesehen hab, ist, dass die so große Maschinen haben, die von einer Rolle drucken. Das Papier ist dann irgendwie so anderthalb Meter breit. Also wirklich so eine riesen Rollen. Und anderthalb Meter breit, da müssen sie halt für mich dann nochmal anderthalb Meter rausdrucken und dann hab ich anderthalb, mal anderthalb Meter. Und das wär doch genauso mein Ding irgendwie in ungefähr der Größe. Und dann kannst du dich dann in deiner Freitag hinsetzen und mit einem Adding und mit blauen Farben und allen verschiedenen Farben kannst du dann da die Datenleitung nachzeichnen oder keine Ahnung. Nee, weiß ich nicht, aber könnte man.
Das hört sich ja an, als würdest du das jetzt machen im Winter.
Na, da ich ja mir dieses 8-Bit-Ding hier mit dem 8-Bit-Prozessor angeguckt hab und verstanden hab wie Michael Coat und weiß nicht, was alles funktioniert. Also theoretisch ist das Ding verstehbar. Und da ich den Assembler davon in- und auswendig kenne, also das kann jetzt nicht so schwer sein.
Aber woran erkennt man denn hier die Transistoren irgendwie?
Ja, da muss man noch ein bisschen dran üben.
Weil ich sehe jetzt hier nur so Kontakte, aber ich sehe keine Transistoren in dem Sinne.
Ja, dann müssen wir mal mit Starbuck reden.
Der kann das.
Das ist ja auch nur eine Schicht. Da gibt es ja dann wahrscheinlich noch mehrere Schichten.
Das ist nur ein JPEG jetzt. War der schon Multilayer? Sondern nur oben und unten?
Ja, aber es gibt halt die Metallseite und dann noch irgendwie die andere Seite. Man könnte jetzt nochmal die andere Seite suchen, aber die andere Seite sieht optisch nicht so spannend aus. Deswegen ist das hier schon das Richtige.
Na ja, aber hat was.
Auf jeden Fall. Und du hast jetzt hier welche Revision? Weil es steht jetzt hier irgendwo. Da ganz rechts unten. Nee, da C97R hast du hier gerade. Genau. Und das andere, was höher auflösender ist, das ist RG2. Dafür gibt es dann so Errata-Dokumente, wo steht, warum die was an welcher Revision geändert haben.
Würde auch einen schönen Wandteppich machen.
Könnte man hier, wie heißt die Frau, mit denen die Dinger da webt und strickt und macht und tut?
Na, das solltest du dir vorher überlegen, was du genau meinst. Bei weben und stricken ist nicht dasselbe.
Weben eher.
Also bei 4 Maschen pro Pixel, bei 25.000 Pixel.
Hat man ein bisschen zu tun.
Da hast du auf jeden Fall einen großen Hals. So einen Hals hast du da.
Zeig dir auf jeden Fall, wie man strickt, wenn du das machst.
Hab ich schon mal probiert in meinem Leben früher. Das kam nicht so gut.
Das wär doch echt mal ein Projekt. Wir stricken uns in einem Prozessor.
Bei meiner Oma, ich hab Goubelin gemacht. Oder wie heißt das?
Goubelin.
Ich hab Teppich geknüpft. Strickliesel hab ich auch gemacht. Also ich hab da so einige Sachen hinter mir.
Tim kann seinen Namen tanzen. Das musst du erstmal toppen.
Ich kann auch Nähmaschine ohne elektrisch. Aber so richtig gut. Hab ich alles gemacht.
Warte mal, meinst du grad... Die Frage ist grad, was du meinst auf so eine Nähmaschine, wirklich meinst du? Mit Fußantrieb? Hab ich auch noch eine obenstehend?
Mir sind elektrische Nähmaschinen bis heute irgendwie, kommen die mir komisch vor.
Den hast du mit meiner noch nicht genäht. Aber da lass ich auch ehrlich gesagt niemanden ran.
Ich war eins mit der Nähmaschine.
Ja, du musst halt richtig, genau. Du musst mit so einer Fußnähmaschine halt so einen Rhythmus finden, wie du mit der arbeitest.
Das fand ich irgendwie geil.
Ansonsten läuft hier unten rund.
Dann hab ich lange Zeit keinen Kontakt mit Nähmaschinen mehr gehabt. Dann gab es so elektrische und die mal so Schalter an.
Nee, du musst natürlich auch... Nähmaschinen, da musst du halt...
Mit Gefühl rangehen.
Mit Gefühl, und du musst Qualität kaufen, wo du halt die Geschwindigkeit...
Gut variieren kannst.
Komplett runter regeln kannst, dass selbst wenn du wie ein Elefant auf diesem Antrittspedal stehst, sie nur sehr langsam vorwärts geht. Weil ansonsten macht das ja überhaupt keinen Sinn, eine Nähmaschine zu haben, die nicht so ganz langsam nähen kann, weil wenn du komplizierte Teile hast, willst du natürlich den Stoff mitführen und langsam um die Ecke nähen oder was auch immer.
Aber sag mal, hier gibt's schon so Unternehmen, wo ich irgendwie meinen PNG einreiche und die mir nach PNG Teppich knüpfen?
China, Kinder.
Ich hab Unternehmen gesagt, wie die das machen, das ist mir egal. Die wollen aufleben.
Das ist ein geiler Wandeppich.
Ehrlich gesagt, ein Wandeppich, ich weiß nicht, wo ihr aufgewachsen seid, aber meine Großeltern hatten das Gefühl, in jedem Raum hängen.
Es gab halt keine Heizung, musste isoliert werden.
Das ist eine gute Akustik, man. Hat der Tim da hinten auch. Aber es ist kein Wandeppich.
Du hast es ja nicht in jedem Raum hängen. Du hast es halt nur im Mainboard sozusagen. Also im CPO-Raum.
Da hast du ja die Fusselfransen, wo dir nicht nur... na egal.
Was du als Kind eigentlich in der Schule auch immer, wenn du irgendwie Langeweile hattest, Stift genommen und dir so deine Traumwohnungen gemalt. Hast du so eine Phase? Wo man so Grundrisse und wie man sich so ein Haus zusammenbauen würde.
Ich hab die Fimms gespielt, da könnt ich dich...
Das stimmt, das ist die eine Sache.
Ich hab zuhause noch die Level, die Dungeons von Barstel auf Karo-Papier.
Ja, aber vielleicht, wenn man sich jetzt so ein Haus bauen würde...
Abgesehen davon, ich hab mein Zimmer gefüllt, jede drei Wochen umgeräumt. Ich brauchte diesen Zettel nicht unbedingt. Also weißt du so, ich hab eh ständig so ein räumliches...
Okay, das ist so, aber irgendwie explored man das auf jeden Fall. So und wenn man jetzt mal so sagt, das Ding ist doch immer, wenn du jetzt genug Geld in die Hand gedrückt bekommen würdest und du könntest dir das Haus bauen, was du, wovon deiner träumt, ja?
Dann kauf ich mir keinen Wandteppich, weil das weckt wirklich schlechte Erinnerungen.
Nein, aber du würdest vielleicht dein, du könntest ja dein, dein, dein, dein Haus-Layout sozusagen so machen, wie eine CPU gelayoutet ist.
Weißt du, an was mich eine CPU...
Das Wohnzimmer ist halt die CPU. Da, wo er am meisten abgeht. Schlafzimmer ist dann halt der Storage, der...
Wenn du da rauszoomst, ich finde, das sieht aus wie ein Elektrizitätswerk von oben.
Es gibt ja den berühmten Film, den wir auch schon öfter hatten, das ist der Kojanis Katsi. Da wechselt der am Ende vom Film zwischen Los Angeles, glaube ich, von oben und so Dye Shots immer so hin und her. Und das sieht ziemlich gleich aus.
Es gibt in der Tat in der Tate Modern gerade eine Ausstellung, glaube ich, ist das über Contemporary Makers on the Loom mit Waving. Waving? Der Webrahmen.
Leute, die am Webrahmen was machen, freu ich. Aber keine Dye-Shots weben. Dye-Shots. Fotos von Professoren.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich ein Pädekolleg gelernt habe. Das geht bestimmt auch.
Naja, das Coole wäre ja, wenn du das Ding dann auch gleich mit konduktiven Fäden webst und die CPU dann auch funktioniert als Teppich. Dann kannst du dir immer noch mal so eine funktionierende CPU auf den Boden legen oder an die Wand hängen.
Wie das eben so ist, da hat man ja häufiger so einen Bedarf danach, dass man am Esstisch sitzt.
Das hätte ich auch professioneller einspielen können. Hier, steck das hier rein, dann kannst du es auch richtig einspielen.
Haha, steck das hier rein. Ist das ein Lightning?
Das ist mein neues Feature hier im Studio.
Aber es geht ins iPhone.
Was? Ach, im iPhone spielst du das ab.
Klar.
Unprofessionell. Findest du?
Hab ich immer dabei.
Wenn du das da reinsteckst, kannst du direkt hier in den Mix rein spielen.
Ja, aber kann ich nicht.
Wieso nicht?
Das ist ein iPhone.
In dein Computer! Ja, aber da hab ich das nicht. Hat das Ding USB-C? Ach, der hat wieder keinen USB-A, ne?
Das auch nicht. Außer hat der kein Körniskratz, der Computer.
Das ist ständiger Quatsch.
Hab ich euch abgelenkt, ihr wart irgendwo gerade.
Wo wir von schönen Traumhäusern und spezieller Architektur sprechen, ich muss unbedingt einen Filmtipp loswerden. Filmtipp. Filmtipp. Kein alter Film. Brandneu. Ich war im Kino. Ich krieg's mit dem Pfeifen grad nicht hin.
Liddy ist keine Pfeife, geht nicht.
Was hast du denn Schönes gesehen, Tim?
Ich habe den zweiten Teil gesehen von The Incredibles. Und The Incredibles ist ohnehin der beste Pixar-Film, den es sowieso jemals gab. Von allen ist das einfach meine total unangefochtene Nummer eins. Ich kenne nichts, was besser gleichzeitig für Kinder und Eltern gleichzeitig lustig ist. Kinder lachen und Eltern lachen und beide lachen gleichzeitig an derselben Stelle über unterschiedliche Sachen. Und abgesehen, dass das Ding rein von der Animation, wie immer bei Pixar, sowieso perfekt ist, fand ich einfach diese Story an sich super. Die Superhelden, die in der Gesellschaft verachtet sind. Und dann haben wir irgendwie wieder neue Bösewichter. Sie müssen wieder ihre alten Kräfte aufbringen und einbringen. Der erste Film war schon fantastisch. Wie lange ist der jetzt eigentlich her? Es hat Jahre gedauert. Der erste Film ist von 2004. Also es hat jetzt 14 Jahre.
14 Jahre hat es gedauert, das ist echt nicht zu fassen.
Und Brad Bird hat auf jeden Fall den Nachfolger gemacht. Und er ist super. Er ist genauso toll wie der erste, wenn nicht toller. Alle geliebten Figuren aus dem ersten Film sind wieder da. Und wenn ihr Incredibles noch nicht gesehen habt, dann fehlt euch was in eurem Leben. Den müsst ihr euch anschauen. Und danach geht ihr sofort ins Kino. Guckt euch den zweiten Teil an, weil er ist auch total toll. Allein schon wegen Edna Moules. Die dürft ihr dir besonders zu sagen. Letty, Edna ist nämlich erstens die Coolste in dem ganzen Film mit Abstand. Und sie ist auch die Designerin. Sie macht die coolen Klamotten für Superhelden. Und sie ist, wie soll ich sagen? Sie ist very opinionated. Also sie hat wirklich eine klare Meinung zu allem. Und vor allem kann sie es nicht ausstehen, wenn irgendwie andere Designer für ihre Superhelden irgendwelche Klamotten machen.
Die Brille wie sie hast du schon.
Stimmt. Hast du Edna Moules noch nie gesehen?
Doch, ich hab ein Bild vor Augen von ihr. Und ich überlege gerade, weil sie erinnert mich wahnsinnig an eine andere Designerin und ich frage mich gerade, ob sie...
Das kann, ja doch, sie ist nach irgendwas geschneidert. Sie ist eine Anspielung, aber ich weiß nicht an wen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall total mega super lustig. Und es gibt sogar, warte mal, es gibt es noch so, ich glaube in diesen Teaser-Filmen gab es sogar noch einen speziellen, da war noch so ein spezieller Etna-Molls-Clip sogar, wo diese ganze Geschichte noch... Das muss ich noch mal rausführen. Etna Mode? Hab ich Molls gesagt? Etna Mode.
Wie Mode.
Ah, The Best of Etna Mode. Nee, das ist auch was, aber es gab irgendeinen...
Wir hatten einen fucking langen Wikipedia-Artikel, der ist länger als viele echte Menschen.
Etna Mode? Das finde ich ja so toll in der englischen Wikipedia, dass da diese ganzen virtuellen Charaktere auch... Wow, das ist ja unglaublich. Ah, Linda Hunt ist sozusagen...
An sie.
Wer ist Linda Hunt? Eine Actress ist sie, okay. Also keine Designerin. Also du hast Incredibles nicht gesehen, Letty? Das geht nicht.
Soll ich das auf die Liste? Letty, das geht so nicht. So kannst du... Ohne diese Filme kannst du dich nicht weiter...
Genau die Liste. Da schreibst du das ganz nach oben. Gleich das nächste ist die Incredibles. Und ich weiß, dass du mich schon wieder mit diesem...
Was erzählt mir der alte Mann schon wieder?
Dein alter Scheiß, der ist auch komplett aus der Mode gekommen. Was willst du eigentlich von mir? Aber ich sag jetzt einfach so lange ja ja, bis es vorbei ist. Ist mir egal. Machs einfach trotzdem.
Das heißt, ich guck mir das dann gleich noch auf Netflix an.
Du wirst ja hingesperrt und erst wieder rausgelassen, wenn du den Film gesehen hast.
Ja, ich bin gespannt. Aber interessant, es gibt eine Designerin, die macht aber überwiegend Frauenunterwäsche. Das war dann wahrscheinlich nicht die Vorlage für sie, aber ich finde, die sieht genauso aus wie Superhelden, Frauenunterwäsche. Chantal Thomas. Aber ja, Frauenunterwäsche und Superhelden-Kleidung ist vielleicht auch von der Elastizität und auf jeden Fall sehr körperanliegend.
Und keine capes. Sollte es tatsächlich unter unseren Hörern, was ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, aber sollte es tatsächlich unter unseren Hörern Leute geben, die noch nicht die Incredibles gesehen haben. Insbesondere, wenn ihr Kinder habt, ist Incredibles nochmal lustig, weil es ja sozusagen nicht, also ich hab ja schon erwähnt, es ist ja gleichzeitig witzig für Kinder und für Erwachsene auf eine fantastische Art und Weise gleichzeitig. Und das Parenting ist auch selber an sich nochmal so ein Thema in dem Film. Und von daher für Leute mit Kindern einfach nochmal allein schon deshalb nochmal komisch. Und wie sagt Edna Mode so schön in dem neuen Film, Done properly, parenting is a heroic act. Und kurze Pause und sie schaut ihn dann nochmal an und sagt, Done properly. Ich geb mir's ruhig. Man kann auch Witze, Filme nicht erzählen, die Leute nicht kennen. Ich weiß, das ist alles ganz furchtbar. Aber dir geht es genauso mit Filmen, die du kennst, toll findest und andere Leute kennen die nicht.
Du hast immer noch nicht Only Lovers Left Alive gesehen. Schäm dich jetzt erstmal ein bisschen. Das sagst du nämlich auch schon seitdem ich das erste Mal im Podcast saß.
Okay, das hol ich nach.
Gibt's beides bei Netflix. Soll ich noch ein paar Animes sagen, die ihr nicht kennt?
Holy Lover's The Last of the Life gibt's bei Netflix?
Gab's zumindest mal, ja.
Tilda Swinton und so.
Guck ich mir an. stimmt.
Also, ich find wir hätten unsere Diskussion über Statistik, Visualisierung und Medizin geübt.
Lass uns über Statistik reden. Lass uns der Welt erklären, warum die Letty wichtig ist.
Nein!
Ich kann noch so einen Aha-Moment geben, wo ihr wahrscheinlich sagen werdet, ja, alt, kenn ich, weiß ich doch, wovon redest du eigentlich? Aber mal ehrlich, wisst ihr warum upper case und lower case, also die Buchstaben?
So heißen?
Weil es da von der Taste gab?
Möchtest du es erzählen, das ist deine Vorhand.
Ich lass jetzt Dennis erst mal raten.
Weil die Setzlinge, die die Drucker früher, als es eine Oberkiste und eine Untere Kiste gab? Ich hätte hier bei dieser Rateshow früher mit dem Glatzkopf-Typie mit den vier Leuten, die da saßen, mit dem Schweizer und so, da hätte ich sitzen können, die immer so geraten haben. Kenn ich ja nicht, aber du vielleicht.
Und warum ist lower case lower case und upper case upper case?
Na, weil upper case ist weiter weg und kommt man nicht so schnell ran, deswegen lower case hat man ja mehr mit zu tun mit kleinen Buchstaben, die braucht man öfter, also sind die näher.
Perfekt. Wirklich?
Das ist ja simpel alles.
Gehört das zu diesen Dingen, wo ich mir dachte so, wusstest du das eigentlich schon mal? Ja vielleicht, aber ist dir wieder entfallen, trotzdem immer wieder interessant, das wieder neu zu lernen. Das ist so ein bisschen wie mit Alzheimer. Das ist einfach total super.
Ich bin ja gespannt.
Na ja, man lernt jeden Tag neue Leute kennen.
Kann ich das so stehen lassen?
Nein, musst du auch gar nicht.
Wir waren ja aber vorhin gerade bei Entschuldigung.
Aber es ist schon was dran. Also ich meine, Dinge entfallen einem. Und dann kommt man nach Jahren wieder mal drauf. So lernt das noch mal komplett. Merkt dann erst am Ende, dass man das schon mal wusste. Und das ist irgendwie faszinierend.
Hab ich eine Frage, will's wissen, suche in Google nach der Antwort. Und findest deinen eigenen Blog eintragen. Ich hab ja keinen Blog. Aber entweder im harmlosen Fall habe ich die Frage schon mal früher gestellt und irgendjemand hat sie beantwortet. Oder ich hab schon mal jemandem die Frage selber beantwortet und hab's aber vergessen.
Ja, und das Internet führt einem irgendwie dann seiner eigenen Vergangenheit entgegen. Also ich bin auch schon bei eigenen Blog-Einträgen gelandet. Da hat man so gesagt, hat dich schon mal mehr interessiert als derzeit. Bloggt ihr eigentlich?
Ich hab früher gebloggt. Über meine ganzen Nähsachen in der Tat. Und bin auch gerade am Überlegen, ob ich wieder anfange, weil ich jetzt zwar ein bisschen einen anderen Fokus habe. Und so Alltagsklamotten da, die ja immer eh schwarz sind, schwer fotografierbar sind. Aber ich versuche jetzt ja wirklich viel, viel mehr so Outdoor-Gedöns zu nähen. Und so Gier ein bisschen. Und darüber überlege ich einfach nur für mich, erstmal nur so zu verbloggen. Und das ist ja auch der Hauptgrund, warum ich Instagram so liebe. Ah, ist die Welt da viel, viel schöner als auf Twitter? Warum? Weil die Leute das auf Twitter benutzen.
Und ich will dann klicken und da kann ich das Bild nicht zoomen. Ich kann gar nichts da machen, das ist voll nervig.
Ja, das stimmt, das ist doof. Aber ich find's halt ganz cool, so in einem Nähkontext, um sich halt mal Inspiration zu suchen, um zu gucken, wie Schnittmuster in Wirklichkeit aussehen. Also für so was find ich das schon ganz cool. Ich weiß nicht, also für diese gesamte Maker-Szene, wo du halt eher so Maker-Creative-Gramen hast, was halt, ja, so ein bisschen Show-and-Tell in dem Maker-Bereich finde ich das schon ganz cool. Deswegen nutze ich das dann halt auch sehr, sehr gern. Und ich mein, du findest halt, es gibt halt so eine antiquare Seite, wo Leute so Pattern-Reviews machen zu verschiedenen Schnittmustern. Aber die ist, a, ist diese Seite wirklich aus dem letzten Jahrhundert und b, kommst du an die Bilder und Reviews nur ran, wenn du da eingeloggt bist. Und da die halt so hässlich ist, so wirklich abartig hässlich ist, hab ich es noch nie übers Herz gebracht, mich da anzumelden. Und so ist halt Pinterest und Instagram da immer eine ganz gute Quelle, um zu gucken, wie so einzelne Schnittmuster halt wirklich am lebenden Objekt aussehen. Weil das, was du halt irgendwie abfotografiert bekommst, so von Fashion-Magazins, ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer die Wahrheit. Oh Wunder.
War nicht da gerade was mit Instagram, irgendwie mit Facebook und den Founders, die jetzt weg sind und in Facebook jetzt anfangen, die Location-Data aus den Fotos raus zu extrahieren und so weiter? Kaum nachdem die Gründer raus sind und die Sperrfrist sozusagen abgelaufen ist?
Das würde mich auch nicht wundern, aber ja. Das Schlimme ist halt, dass du zu Instagram wahrscheinlich keine richtige Alternative hast. Twitter hat irgendwie verschiedene andere Sachen. Also Twitter-Alternativen gibt es ja hier dieses... Ja, genau, dieses Tool. Und dann gab es doch nochmal noch was anderes, was auch ein Dezentrales war, dachte ich. Aber sowas gab es irgendwie noch nie so direkt bei Twitter. Oder hab ich etwas noch nie gefunden. Viele sind halt irgendwann auf Patreon umgestellt, weil sie es genervt hat, dass Instagram die Timeline nicht mehr drin hatte. Ja, genau. Es ist eigentliche, dass du Leute unterstützen kannst, die du unterstützen zu werden findest, egal was sie jetzt machen, wenn sie da einen Account haben. Aber es gab halt auch einige Artes, die explizit gesagt haben, es kotzt mich so sehr an, dass Instagram hier meine Timeline zu saumacht, indem sie halt random irgendwas oben anzeigt. Weil nicht random ist ja, wer die meisten Likes hat, aber das ist ja keine Zeitleiste mehr, sondern mehr so ein vordefinierter Ranking. Genau. Dass sie halt dann gesagt haben, okay, wer meinen Content mag, ich poste.
Sie müssen es ja eh auf Patreon posten.
Das war aber da noch in der Umstellungsphase vor, ich glaube, mir ist es aufgefallen vor fünf Jahren, glaube ich.
Wenn du bei Patreon regelmäßig Geld beziehen willst, dann musst du deinen Content auch auf Patreon annuncen. Das heißt, du hast eh dieses Doppel-Posting und dadurch zieht Offensivbar für die Lightweight-Publikation Patreon sozusagen die Leute auf ihre Plattformen, sodass die anderen Plattformen am Ende nicht obsolet werden, aber quasi da werden die Leute quasi abgezogen. Das ist ein interessanter Effekt.
Ich poste nichts, ich blogge nichts, ich habe nichts zu erzählen und keine Zeit.
Das halte ich ja für ein Gerücht.
Und ich bin nicht gut im Kommunizieren.
Das ist halt eine Sache, die ich ganz gerne auch ausbessern würde. Ausbauen. Kopf. Einfach so ein bisschen besser in dem Schreiben, weil mir ist halt auch aufgefallen, ich fand es auch so ein bisschen doof, dass ich nach meiner Vorlesung, was meine Vorlesung war, nicht noch mal auf, also die Vorlesung, wo ich jetzt speziell über Datenvisualisierung und Datenvisualisierung im Web-Kontext mit die 3JS irgendwie so ein paar Basics erzählt hab meinen Studenten, dass ich das nicht noch mal aufbereitet habe in so eine Blog-Series. Und da bin ich jetzt halt auch am Überlegen, ob ich das noch mal vielleicht im Nachhinein jetzt einfach machen soll, um es für mich selber einfach auch noch mal gut dokumentiert zu haben und nicht nur meine Vorlesungsnotizen habe. Ist das jetzt ein Podcast? Entschuldigung, jetzt lese ich gerade, was der Chat treibt. Ich bin verwirrt. Nein, aber da überlege ich halt in der Tat, ob ich das mal so verschriftliche, dass man es halt auch als Blog, Post, Serie veröffentlichen kann.
Also ich bin ja zutiefst davon überzeugt, dass Mitteilen die effektivste Form des Lernens ist.
Für mich ist Konsumieren, also Lesen die effektivste Form. Aber ich will ja auch lernen.
Ja, aber wenn du sagst, wenn du sagst, was war gerade deine Formulierung, du kannst, also ich meine, dieses, ich hab nichts zu sagen, lass mal gleich mal fallen, aber du kannst nicht kommunizieren, war das deine Formulierung?
Ja, im Prinzip. Also ich kann Leuten was erklären. Ich kann Leuten was beibringen, aber nicht in textueller Form.
Okay, das akzeptiere ich.
Können wir wahrscheinlich alle nicht, dass sie machen ja Podcast.
Wie wär's denn mit einer anderen Form?
Na ich, also im Prinzip habe ich 1, 2, 3, 4 Vorträge gegeben, gehalten zu unterschiedlichen Themen, weil ich es einfach mal ausprobieren wollte, von kleinen Meetups bis hin zu halt größeren Dev-Konferenzen, wo ich halt einfach gesagt habe, okay, ich probier's mal aus und da ist halt primär das Problem, dass ich mal im eigenen Anspruch nicht gerecht werde und danach so frustriert bin mit dem Outcome, dass es für mich keinen Sinn macht, weiter irgendwie große Vorträge zu halten.
Warum wirst du deinem eigenen Anspruch nicht gerecht? Was ist denn dein Anspruch in dem Moment?
Besser zu sein als das, was ich abliefe.
Ja, aber ich meine, das kannst du doch verbessern. Ich meine, wenn du dir das bewusst bist...
Das ist halt Perfektionismus, den du nie erreichen kannst.
Das ist ja völlig in Ordnung.
Ich suche mir dann halt einfach Mittel und Wege, die für mich besser funktionieren. Also ich halte ja eh wissenschaftliche Poster-Präsentation und ich muss ja meine wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten in schriftlicher Form veröffentlichen. Das finde ich soweit okay. Da habe ich auch nicht den Anspruch an mich, das muss perfekt werden, sondern ich will halt das herunterschreiben und das muss gut genug sein. Aber wenn ich jetzt halt irgendwie auf einer Developer-Konferenz mich hinstelle und sage, ich möchte euch jetzt was beibringen oder ich möchte euren Horizont erweitern, habe ich halt einfach einen höheren Anspruch als einfach zu sagen, okay hier das ist meine Arbeit, macht damit was ihr wollt.
Höher Anspruch?
An mich selbst.
Ja, aber was heißt das? Höher Anspruch? Wo genügst du dir denn nicht?
Möchtest du das jetzt wirklich aufgedröselt haben?
Ja, deswegen frag ich das ja.
Beispiel, es gibt von mir auf YouTube zwei Vorträge.
Dürfen wir die verlinken oder ist das schon nicht ganz wert?
Nee, das denke ich in Ordnung. Ich denke, man könnte die finden. Ja, wurde glaube ich schon gefunden. Der eine ist auf Englisch. Ich finde meinen Englisch so im Alltag okay, aber ich finde meinen Englisch nicht gut genug für Vorträge.
Das kann aber auch eine Stresssituation sein.
Und auch schon wieder dein erhöhter Anspruch.
Ja, natürlich. Aber er hat mich jetzt nach, wo ist mein Anspruch zu hoch für mich selbst. Und der andere ist auf Deutsch. Englisch ist meine Sprache nicht gut genug. Mir wurde angemerkt, dass ich nicht selbstbewusst genug rüberkomme bei meinen Vorträgen. Also entweder ich fühle mich wohl, dann bin ich nicht selbstbewusst genug. Oder ich fühle mich absolut unwohl, aber dann habe ich ein professionelles Auftreten. Was für mich beides irgendwie...
Das passt nicht zusammen.
Naja, das ist leider so.
Hast du mal darüber nachgedacht, vielleicht dein Wissen und deine Forschung in einen Science Slam vortragen?
Ich bin nicht lustig. Ich habe keinerlei Humor. Was soll ich bei einem Science Slam? Ich bin auch nicht wortgewandt.
Du hast keinerlei Humor?
Nee, das ist schwierig.
Das heißt nicht, dass du keinen Humor hast. Du kannst ja einen schwierigen Humor haben.
Aber ich stelle mich nicht auf die Bühne und sage, hey, ich bin lustig und ihr könnt hier bestimmt über lachen.
Das muss man, ja, weiß nicht. Also man kann ja Humor auf verschiedenen Ebenen...
Science Slam ist so genau das Gegenteil von dem, was ich könnte. Ich kann einfach staubtrockene Vorträge halten, Workshops zu ganz spezifischen Themen.
Letzi, stimmt das?
Nee, das würde ich auch nicht sagen. Aber ich sehe das mit dem Science Slam halt ähnlich. Ich wurde letztens auch angefragt, da fand ich die Beschreibung auch so, da dachte ich mir so, wie was? So nach dem Motto, wir suchen etwas zwischen Lightning Talk und Science Slam. Und ich war so, das eine befindet sich links, das andere befindet sich rechts und irgendwie so dazwischen ist alles mögliche. Aber für mich kommen diese beiden Themen nicht zusammen. Und ich finde Science Slam halt, ich weiß nicht, also ich finde die halt auch selten so richtig, also ich bin da auch, das Medium gefällt mir glaube ich selber nicht so gut, als dass ich es machen wollen würde, also deswegen finde ich, ich weiß nicht, müsste man sich vielleicht auch mal mehr damit beschäftigen. Podcasten klappt schon mal gut, danke. Das finde ich in der Tat eher am spannendsten, irgendwie so Podcasten, wo du nicht direkt mit Leuten sichtbaren Kontakt hast, weil das finde ich ist auch nach wie vor ganz schön schwierig. Also ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob ich es schlimmer in der Vorlesung fand, die ich gehalten habe. Das hat im Übrigen, und das solltest du, das weiß ich nicht, wir sollten mal vielleicht eine Lehrauftrag für dich organisieren, Tala, weil ich finde, das hat mir sehr, sehr viel Confidence gegeben, so für mein Auftreten auch auf einer Bühne vielleicht, weil dadurch, dass du irgendwie deine eigene Lehrveranstaltung hast, das ist die ersten vier Male, stehst du da halt wirklich schweißgebadet, und das meine ich halt wirklich so da vorne nach diesen vier Stunden und bist durch für den Tag. Also ich weiß nicht, ich kann mich noch gut erinnern, ich weiß nicht, ob ich die nach den ersten beiden Lehrveranstaltungen dann gepodcastet habe mit euch oder ob ich völligstens durch war und kann mich auch gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Aber das hat euch halt verdrängt.
Ja, das hat euch alles verdrängt. Aber was ich halt gemerkt habe, diese krasse Nervosität, die man am Anfang hatte mit, ich muss super perfektionistisch sein und das legst du zum Glück irgendwann ab und du merkst halt so, dass du diese Confidence halt einfach bekommst, zu sprechen vor anderen und dann hat es mich auch am Ende nicht mehr gestört, wenn einer halb eingeschlafen ist. Und dann dachte ich mir halt so, ja okay, mir ging es halt. Also es ist nicht unbedingt meine Person, sondern ich war auch mal Student, ich hab irgendwie auch mal...
Wir haben auch in Vorlesungen gepennt.
Wir haben auch in Vorlesungen gepennt, waren auch am aufnüchternen Vorlesungen. Also das kennt man ja alles, wenn man da mal Student war. Also weißt du, dann hab ich halt irgendwann auch gemerkt, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt jede Reaktion von dem Publikum, musst du dir zu Herzen nehmen. Also gerade so diese Einschlafsituation oder Genen ist dann halt auch so ein Ding, wo man schnell sich selber verunsichert fühlt.
Was, wenn man selber gähnt?
Nee, wenn andere gähnen und du siehst das. Und du siehst das aber gerade eben zufällig wahrscheinlich, weil du da gerade hinguckst und jemand gähnt.
Weil zu wenig Sauerstoff im Raum ist.
Ja, das war auch noch so ein Problem.
Also ich will nochmal einen Vorschlag machen, nochmal irgendwie das mit diesem Humor und der Perfektion aufgreifen. Also, man kann ja, es gibt ja nicht nur eine Art und Weise, wie man jetzt so eine Wissensvermittlung macht. Und klar ist nur eine einfache Regel, wenn man da jetzt sehr lustig rüberkommt und dann vielleicht auch noch so total hilarious und immer noch irgendwie einen lockeren Spruch am Start hat und da tausend Witze eingebaut hat in seinen Talk. Okay, das kann irgendwie ankommen, das kann auch funktionieren. Gerade beim Science Slam, aber ich will es jetzt nicht so sehr daran festmachen, sondern generell eigentlich beim Talk, ist eigentlich sehr viel wichtiger, dass man immer das Gefühl hat, okay, die Person, die mir da jetzt versucht, etwas zu vermitteln, versteht auch was davon. Das hat sehr viel mehr damit zu tun, wie klar man da die Erzählereienfolge macht und was man wie ausführlich beschreibt, wie viel Zeit man sich für die einzelnen Sachen nimmt und wie sehr man quasi, ist ja ein bisschen wie beim Podcasting auch, man hat ja keine unmittelbare Reaktion der Leute, die am Zuhören, also gerade bei meinen Interviewformaten ist das immer wieder so ein Thema, man muss irgendwie so ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, wie schnell man halt voranschreitet, wo man irgendwie Dinge zusammenfasst, kompaktiert etc. Das ist auch nichts, was man beim allerersten Mal immer hinbekommt, aber wenn man so ein Thema zwei, drei Mal immer wieder auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise vorträgt, dann kriegt man schon schnell raus, dann eben an den unmittelbaren Reaktionen, okay, das hat nicht funktioniert, hier haben sie irgendwie mit den Augen gedreht, und dann refind man das und lernt dabei, worauf es eigentlich ankommt. Wenn man diese Sicherheit im Thema hat, und dadurch auch beeindrucken kann, dass man eben effizient und gut verständlich vorträgt, und die Leute so Aha-Momente haben, und sind so, ich verstehe das ja wirklich, obwohl es total kompliziert ist, dann schafft man eben auch so eine gewisse Autorität, die nicht nur einem so eine Selbstsicherheit gibt, sondern die einem auch Raum gibt, an der Stelle auch die Persönlichkeit dann wieder mehr zum Spielen zu bringen. Und wenn man halt jetzt nicht albern und lustig sein will, kann man glaube ich auch eine Art Humor auch über die Stringenz und den Perfektionismus erreichen.
Ich habe einen Haufen Portal-Referenzen in einem meiner Vorträge drin.
Das ist auch eine Methode. Ich würde noch ein weiteres Format, wo du sagtest, was war das zwischen Lightning Talk und Sign Slam? Also etwas, was ich selber nur ein einziges Mal leider gemacht habe, aber jederzeit bereit wäre wieder zu machen, ist Petschakucha. Sagt euch das was?
Dass die Folien durchlaufen und man darf nur so viel Zeit irgendwie.
Du hast 20 Slides. Die 20 Slides sind Bilder im Wesentlichen. Also kann irgendwas sein. Also kann man sich jetzt über das Detail, was da drauf sein kann. Also du hast 20 Slides. Und jedes Slide steht exakt 20 Sekunden auf dem Bildschirm. Und schreitet von alleine weiter. Das heißt du gibst vorher deine 20 Slides ab. Und eine Software sorgt dafür, dass jedes Bild 20 Sekunden gezeigt wird. Kein Klicker, nichts. Du wirst eins mit dieser Bilder-Sequenz, nur hast 20 Sekunden Zeit, pro Bild dieses Bild für deine Erzählung arbeiten zu lassen. Ich hab mal so einen Vortrag über Blinkenlights gehalten, irgendwo in Brüssel, ist leider nicht aufgezeichnet worden. Ich glaube, ich war total super. Ganz ehrlich, ganz zurückhaltend formuliert. Aber ich war total super. Ich hab's wirklich toll gemacht. Die Leute waren begeistert. Und es war ein sehr dankbares Thema, auch vom Visuellen her und so weiter. Ich hatte schon vorher schon viele Vorträge über Blinkenlights gehalten und war dann eher durch Zufall in dieser Situation, dass ich gefragt wurde, hier im Petscher Kutscher und so weiter, willst du nicht aufmachen? Ich so, klar, mach ich. Hab mir irgendwie meine 20 Bilder rausgesucht und die an meiner Story entlang erzählt. Und hab auch in dem Moment sehr viel mehr als sonst noch über das Thema eben in Form einer Geschichtenerzählung nachgedacht. Und das war so irre, von diesem automatisch ablaufenden Bilderrahmen getriggert zu werden und zu wissen, du bist jetzt im Takt, du hast überhaupt gar keine Chance. Du kannst nicht einmal verzögern, sondern du musst einfach weiter erzählen, weil es bleibt nicht stehen. Und das ist für die Leute super, weil du hast exakt 6 Minuten 40 Dauer. Alle Vorträge sind genau gleich lang. Und wenn du es gut hinbekommen hast, dann hast du mit der letzten Sekunde deinen letzten Punkt gemacht und dann ist auch Schluss. Wum, runter von der Bühne und zack.
Die hohe Kompetenz der Präsentation.
Es ist ein geiles, geiles, sehr unterhaltsames Format.
Ja, aber ich glaube sowas, ich finde Lightning Talk hört sich erstmal ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen einfacher an, aber gerade so um Erfahrung zu sammeln, finde ich so Lightning Talk und einen normalen Talk, der bei 30 Minuten, also ist ja mal so Lightning Talk, 30-minütiger oder Stundentalk, damit kann man so anfangen, seine Kompetenz aufzubauen und so Petscher Kutscher oder halt auch so ein Science Lab. Also ich würde halt sagen, das ist halt nicht was, womit du am Anfang meistens anfangen würdest, oder? Also ich meine, höher. Genau, das sehe ich nämlich auch eher so, dass ich mir das eher zutrauen würde, wenn ich einfach schon so ein paar Sachen auf einer Bühne mal gemacht habe.
Nein, nein, es ist hilfreich, weil es eine Reduktion ist. Du verfängst dich gar nicht in irgendeinem Scheiß. Du kommst gar nicht auf die Idee, irgendeinen Slide mit 30 Sätzen und 50 Bullenpoints zu machen.
Nee, das finde ich halt, also Slides sind ja eh... Puh, ich muss mal ein bisschen... Genau, aber ich mag sie halt auch eher, ich bin jetzt nicht irgendwie wie bei... Wie heißt dieses Programm? Powerpoint, wo du dann... Und noch ein Bulletpoint mehr, wird die gesamte Schriftgröße kleiner oder so eine Scheiße. Nee, das ist bei LaTeX, oder? Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Hab ich so noch nicht gesehen, aber...
Wo du halt merkst, du nutzt grad definitiv den Raum, den du zur Verfügung hast, für zu viele Dinge. Aber ja.
Also ich hab die letzten Vorträge... Immer wenn ich einen neuen Vortrag mache, dann komme ich immer so an... Am Anfang hänge ich immer so ein bisschen fest, denk mir so, was machst du jetzt für Slides? Und dann trage ich doch schon über die Zeit so einen gewissen Slides-Style von mir her. Wenn man so meine Vorträge in den letzten Jahren so angeschaut hat, da ging es ja immer viel um Podcasting. Die haben sich dann so in seinem Slides-Erscheinung doch sehr geähnelt und ich hab halt immer wieder Varianten, Varianten, Varianten davon gemacht. Und bin dann irgendwie auch weg von meinen... Also ich mach halt immer Step-by-Step. Also während ich erzähle, klicke ich die einzelnen Elemente weiter. Slides bauen sich ja auf. Das waren aber meistens Bullet Points. Mittlerweile hab ich Schnauze voll von Bullet Points. Es war halt nicht so nervig, weil ich sie halt Stück für Stück revealed habe. Das Schlimmste ist ja, machst einen neuen Slide, zehn Thesen irgendwie, alle fangen an, sich alles von vorne bis unten durch zu lesen. Und du hängst irgendwie immer noch an dem ersten Punkt fest und keiner weiß, worum es jetzt eigentlich gerade geht. Und das hilft halt irgendwie alles nicht weiter. Wenn du Stück für Stück machst, geht's. Da dachte ich mir so, warum dann nicht sowieso immer einen neuen Slide? Mittlerweile bin ich halt runter auf irgendwie ein paar Worte pro Slide und ab und zu mal ein Bild. Und das funktioniert irgendwie viel besser. Aber es muss ein Flow drin sein. Den Flow könnte ich aber mit den Bildern ganz genauso herstellen. Also es ist gar nicht so, dass jetzt so ein großer Unterschied ist. Pecha Kucha ist halt insofern cool, weil ich finde, dass diese 20 Sekunden ein vielleicht so ein bisschen random gewählt, aber dann doch ganz passender Zeitraum ist, wie lange man eigentlich auf so ein Bild starren will. Also es gibt dir genug Gelegenheit, das wahrzunehmen. Sag mal so 10 Sekunden brauchst du vielleicht wirklich, um es so inhaltlich auf dich wirken zu lassen, und dann hast du halt noch 5 Sekunden zum Reinen wieder rausfäden, und dann kommt irgendwie das nächste und du weißt auch, dass das so ist. Und dann fängst du einfach an dein Thema. Also jedes Thema kann man erzählen mit 20 Visualisierungen. Also egal, ich will euch das gar nicht aufregen. Ich sag nur, Kommunikation ist möglich. Man kann auch zufriedenstellen, kommunizieren, vortragen etc. Auch ohne jetzt die ganze Zeit witzig sein zu müssen oder so. Man kann den Humor auch sehr fein einspielen. Ich meine, du willst mir nicht erzählen, dass du keinen Humor hast, Tala. Natürlich hast du Humor.
So lange es mit Tod und Blut zu tun hat, hat sie richtig viel Humor.
Ja, und wenn es dieses morbide Element ist. Und wenn du sowas schon mit trockener Stimme am Anfang einführst, sagst du, jetzt wird es etwas morbid.
Aber der Unterschied, der wichtig ist, das eine ist, ich würde sagen, meine Vorträge sind nicht schlecht. Ich würde sagen, sie kommen durchaus gut an. Aber das ist etwas ganz anderes, als ich werde meinem eigenen Anspruch gerecht. Mein eigener Anspruch ist zu hoch.
Ja, aber vielleicht hab ich eine gute Idee. Der Tim hat uns doch eigentlich gerade eine gute Idee gebracht. Gisst du, hier eine lustige Todesstatistik, die wir immer aufarbeiten? Du bist gut in Statistik, ich bin gut in Visualisierung. Jetzt erzähl mir doch nicht immer, dass du keine hast.
Ja, wir haben beide das Brain.
Lass uns reich werden mit toten Menschen. Die sind auch witzig.
Ich nehme erstmal meine lebenden und todkranken Menschen.
Ich merk schon, wir kommen ja einfach nicht zusammen.
Wie gesagt, ich probiere ja Sachen aus, ich bringe mich ja weiter Sachen auszuprobieren und muss dann aber auch entscheiden, ich bin ein introvertierter Mensch. Ich muss nicht einfach mich auf jede Bühne stellen und Leuten erzählen.
Das ist aber noch nicht der Punkt. Du, haha, sag die mir!
Du hast es noch nicht genug ausprobiert. Du musst jetzt.
Ich hab schon. Um das aufzuklären, ich wurde halt in der Tat für einen Lightning Talk gefragt und meine erste Reaktion war so, ich hab ja nix zu erzählen und wer hat mir dann gesagt, irgendwie so, äh, Fräulein, du sagst mal schön Ja zu der ganzen Nummer. Wir könnten wirklich mal, wir könnten eigentlich auch eine Vorlesung zusammen machen. Wir müssten nur noch eine Uni finden, die uns toll findet.
Ich hab, äh, wir haben, ich hätte sogar Möglichkeiten, uns in Vorlesungen einzubringen. Also das ist definitiv nicht das Problem.
Gerade so der ganze, ähm, Statistikrahmen zusammen mit Visualisierung.
Ja.
Um halt vielleicht auch so ein paar Sachen anschaulicher darzustellen.
Das ist halt diese, diese lustige kognitive Dissonanz. Zum einen denke ich, weiß ja jeder und wissen ja alle und die andere ist dann...
Ich sag nur Christina.
Ja, oder halt der CCC-Talk.
Jetzt keine Insider pullen, ja.
Es gibt gute und schlechte Dinge.
Ich denke hier im Podcast auch schon mal, das wissen ja eigentlich alle, weil ich lese ja auch nur Internet und... Aber das ist halt nicht so. Viele Leute beschäftigen sich halt nicht so viel oder haben keine Zeit oder mögen es halt auch gerne so ein bisschen aufbereitet schon irgendwie und...
Ja, nicht nur das.
Das ist halt der andere Gedanke. Ich bin aber gar nicht so tief in der Materie drin genug, dass ich mich auf eine Bühne stellen könnte und das vermitteln, weil ich habe ja auch nur solides Halbwissen.
Ja, aber haben wir ja auch. Wir sind ja berühmt für uns solides Halbwissen. Das ist ja quasi ein Stand bei unserer Sendung.
Deshalb bin ich ja hier und fühle mich halbwegs wohl. Nein, ich mache nicht ursprünglich Mathe. Ich mache Medizin, Informatik und Informatik und Statistik als Hobby.
Ja, das stimmt so nicht. Man muss dazu sagen...
Das war die Antwort auf eine Frage im Chat, du musst auch die Frage wiederholen.
Ob Tala ursprünglich Mathe macht, dazu muss man mal spoilern. Während ich mich um den Ruhm und Ehre in den Programmierentutorien verdient gemacht habe, hat Tala das durchgezogen, drei Semester lang in Mathe. Um dann sogar den Informatiker nachzugeben.
Aber das war ja nur FH-Matte und nicht...
Das stimmt, das ist noch mal ein ganz anderer Nummer. Aber das war sehr lustig.
Das hat halt das FH-Matte das Spaß gemacht. Und Statistik macht halt auch wirklich Spaß.
Ja, das ist echt wahr. Statistik ist halt schon echt sexy. Da könnt ihr mit jeder Fancy-Visualisierung kommen. Da geht einfach nichts drüber.
Wir machen Buchhaltungsstatistik.
Na ja, jetzt ist der Zet-
Mit Sativisierung.
Seit 15 Minuten ist die Umsatzsteuer-Voranmeldung-Datline durch.
Aber ich habe ja noch gar keine Umsatzsteuer. Ich muss mir ja überlegen, ob ich dieses Jahr Umsatzsteuer auf meine Richtung... Guck mal, der Chat schreibt schon Katzenbilder. Ich glaube, das ist eine Aufforderung, dass wir jetzt bitte den Mund halten sollen.
Ich möchte abschließend noch sagen, alle Studenten, Doktoranden, Postdocs und Researchers, die irgendwie was ins Ausland machen wollen und kostenlos dahin wollen, guckt euch mal die Programme vom JSPS und vom DAAD an. Die sind meistens alle kostenlos. Schreibt einen Abstract, bewerbt euch und ihr werdet kostenlos in die Welt geschickt.
Nicht nur nach Japan?
Nicht nur nach Japan. Also JSPS ist japanspezifisch. Da ist für das Summer Program zum Beispiel die Deadline Anfang Januar. Ihr braucht einen Host, der euch in Japan aufnimmt. Meistens über die Uni oder man kann einfach, also auf der JSPS-Liste gibt es eine große Liste an Unis, die quasi supporten, die Host stellen. Also man kann einfach da anfragen und es gibt halt so feste Programme. Es gibt Programme bis zwei, drei Jahre.
Falls das mal länger sein darf. Ob das bewirkt du dich bitte nicht?
Ich hab das Angebot bekommen, aber ich darf nicht, weil die Liddy sonst schimpft. Und ich hier meine zwei, drei Jobs hab, die auch schimpfen würden. Aber auf jeden Fall, das ist total cool. Und wenn man es sich im Prinzip leisten kann, sozial und hier Wohnung zwischendurch vermietet hat, kriegt man normalerweise genug Geld, um zumindest vor Ort locker über die Runden zu kommen.
Welche Länder würdest du so empfehlen?
Ich bin noch nicht viel durch die Welt gereist.
Ich habe zwei Städte gesehen, die mich wirklich nachhaltig beeindruckt haben. Kito in Ecuador, da habe ich irgendwie über zwei Wochen jobtechnisch verbracht. Also muss man sich ein bisschen ans Klima gewöhnen und muss sich auch an die Höhe gewöhnen. Aber mein Gott, das war die geilste Stadt, die ich bisher gesehen habe. Also fände ich super spannend. Es ist so diese Mischung von der Stadt, vom Aufbächer der Stadt, von dem, was so drumrum machbar ist. Im Sinne von, du hast irgendwie super schöne Parks, du kannst deinem Freizeitaktivität in deinem Sport nachgehen, du hast irgendwie die hohen Berge. Ich habe es ja leider nicht geschafft, damals da auch joggen zu gehen. Das wäre der Wahnsinn gewesen. Aber auch so diese ganze Stadtinfrastruktur fand ich extrem interessant. Jetzt ist Ecuador, also Quito ist halt auch wahnsinnig. Also wahnsinnig ist vielleicht das übertriebenere Wort, aber es ist schon relativ sicher. Ich weiß, dass Guayaquil, die größere Stadt, glaube ich ein bisschen nicht so safe ist im Vergleich. Also ich weiß nicht, Quito hat mich so von dem Klima, von den Leuten halt auch wahnsinnig beeindruckt. Die fand ich extrem nett und freundlich. Auf der anderen Seite muss man sich halt auch gewiss sein, dass da die ganzen indigenen Völker und die indigenen Menschen, die da wohnen, ganz schön unterdrückt werden. Das ist nervig und da kommt man auch so ein bisschen an die Grenze, das, was man so toleriert. Also ich hab da auch einige angekackt dafür. Die haben das halt ganz offensichtlich gemacht während der UN-Konferenz, dass sie da ein bisschen blöde Sprüche gemacht haben. Aber ansonsten ist es halt echt eine sehr interessante Stadt, eine sehr, ich fand auch irgendwie eine sehr junge Stadt. Ich weiß nicht, ich bin da so ein bisschen rein verliebt, auf jeden Fall kann ich empfehlen. Santiago de Chile fand ich mindestens genauso interessant, aber da war ich viel zu kurz. Da weiß ich gar nicht, wie lange ich war. Chile insgesamt war spannend. Aber leider zu europäisch.
Südamerika ist eh eine Menge zu holen.
Ja, absolut. Auch Costa Rica. Das Mittelamerika, was ist auch ein...
Ich weiß halt, dass die Austauschprogramme...
Die sind sehr wichtig.
Die sind sehr wichtig, ja.
Wenn denen das wichtig ist, sollte uns das auch wichtig sein.
Ich weiß halt, dass die ganzen... Also nach USA die Austauschprogramme und auch nach China die Austauschprogramme sind relativ gut gebucht und haben relativ viel Zulauf. Ich hab aber gehört, dass gerade zum Beispiel sowas wie Japan, die haben jetzt also 20 Leute angenommen und die Chance ist irgendwie eins zu vier. Das heißt, wenn man halbwegs interessantes Forschungsinteresse hat in den Host, ist eine hohe Chance dort angenommen zu werden.
Weil da nicht so viele hinwollen.
Weil es auch gar nicht so bekannt ist. Was ich halt sehr schade finde, weil das ist ein echt cooles Programm. Und generell haben die halt echt coole Programme. Aber das geht halt irgendwie im Massen-E-Mail-Verteiler unter. Und es gibt nicht, keine Ahnung, nicht genug Werbung, nur Werbung auf Japanisch. Andersrum kann man die Programme auch nutzen, um jetzt zum Beispiel japanische Studenten nach Deutschland zu holen. Also da bietet das DAD auch Programme. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt irgendwie woanders eine Uni hat und da Austausch fördern will, auch DAD, die helfen.
Ob man jetzt in China gleich das Social Scoring gratis obendrauf bekommt zum Forschungsaufenthalt?
Auf jeden Fall wirst du in dein Forschungs- kleines Städtchen bzw. Wohntrakt und du darfst dann wahrscheinlich den Komplex auch primär nicht verlassen nach dem, wo du hinkommst. Aber ich hab tolle Geschichten aus chinesischen Hospitals von Ärzten, die dort halt hospitiert haben.
Das erzählen wir dann nächstes Mal.
Vielleicht oder auch vielleicht nicht.
Also jetzt machen wir keine Andeutung über irgendwelche Geschichten, die wir dann doch nicht erzählen. Dennis, was ist mit dir? Schläfst du noch? Ich bin wach. Haben wir's?
Ich würde noch zwei Menschen danken und zwar dem Tobias und dem Mike für Amazon-Geschenke. Ich hab jetzt einen Rubik's Cube bekommen.
Genau, danke Letty. Weil du hast ja letztens schon mal erzählt, dass du so einen Cube bekommen hast. Und dann hab ich mal gegoogelt, was denn so der heiße Shit in Cubes ist. Und, Moment, ich hab den nämlich auf meine Liste gesetzt. Shameless Plugger nennt man das, ne? Ja, denke ich auch. Ich muss das ja nur, weil ich da den gespeichert hab. Los, komm schon, bau dich auf. Und zwar gibt's jetzt welche, die haben so kleine Magneten drin. Das ist jetzt der neueste Scheiß, oder vielleicht nicht der neueste, aber für uns als Cube. Newbies, die sich gerade wieder neu, als Wiedereinsteiger so nennen wir das. Bei den Motorradfahrern heißt das Wiedereinsteiger. Genau. Jedenfalls haben die kleine Magneten drin, dass die sich sozusagen immer wieder in die gerade Position rücken, dass du nicht so eine Halbposition hast, also dass du nicht zu wenig drehst oder zu viel, weil der Magnet so ein bisschen an der Stelle stehen bleiben will, da wo gerade alles passt. Und das hilft wohl beim Schnelldrehen, weil es sind ja so diese Speed-Küber, die überdrehen ja auch manchmal so ein bisschen. Das soll ja nicht passieren. Und der Magnet verhindert das so ein bisschen. Der klickt sozusagen an den richtigen Stellen so ein bisschen. Und das ist der heiße Scheiß gerade.
Also, ich war ja mal Speeddreher und...
Mit deiner einen Minute, ja?
Also, ein gut eingedrehter Cube. Also der ist halt erstmal benutzt und so weiter. Also du musst halt richtig auch mal ein bisschen abschleifen mit den ganzen Plastikdingern. Dann baut man das Ding auseinander, flanscht das Teil mit Vaseline voll und baut's wieder zusammen. Und dann geht das ab. Und dann ist das eigentlich gar nicht so das Problem. Weil du an diesen Punkt der Verkantung eigentlich nicht hinkommst. Weil wenn denn das Ding ein bisschen angeschliffen ist und Vaseline ist da drin, dann kannst du über diese Kanten, da bleibt man einfach nicht hängen.
Hast du dann auch immer gut gefettete Finger gehabt? Also immer sanft weiche Pfötchen?
Ja, heute noch.
Die will man ja genau nicht haben, damit man nicht abrutscht.
Also das, ja das weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht sind die so mega präzise, dass es noch darüber hilft.
Ich kann das nicht sagen.
Aber es ist interessant, dass nach so langer Zeit an den Dingern immer noch so viel researcht wird. Wie alt ist der jetzt eigentlich? Ruis Club, das sind 80er, oder? Wann ist der rausgekommen? 74 erfunden, genau und 80 war Spiel des Jahres. Da hat es so ein bisschen seinen Durchbruch gehabt. Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Ich hab zu Hause immer noch eine Kopie von dem ersten Spiegelartikel, wo zum ersten Mal die Lösung irgendwie drin war.
Das war wegweisend.
Hipp Hippora, ich schmeiß ne Runde, oder so hieß der Artikel.
Wobei sie am Schluss so eine 21 Zug Lösung haben. 22 Zug.
Die ist völlig überholt, die macht niemand mehr.
Genau, da gibt es noch eine 8er und die ist irgendwie cooler.
Aber das war die erste Lösung. Und dann hab ich es nach dieser Lösung damals gelöst.
Auf jeden Fall danke für diese Geschenke. Und was ich auch ganz knuffig fand, ich find es cool, wenn ihr, wenn jemand was schenkt, auch den Zettel mit eurem Namen dazuschreibt. Und da standen auch aufmunternde Worte drauf, dass so ein Mailserver selber zu hosten. Wirklich nicht schwer, es ist echt cool. Darüber freut man sich. Mal gucken, ob ich es mir jetzt mal traue. Nein, das fand ich ernst. Ich fand das cool, weil ich das letztes Mal gesagt hab, na, muss ja nicht gleich sein. Aber ich find das cool, wenn ihr sowas dann auch schreibt. Oder nicht?
Nee, ich fand das, also ich find das cool, wenn jemand sagt so, ey, das geht wirklich. Aber eigentlich, ich finde ich, weil so wenig Leute so Mails zu erwarten, ist das immer noch viel zu schwer das Problem und die Hacker machen es nicht leichter.
Ich hab ja einen am Laufen.
Ich hab ja einen am Laufen, so ist ja nicht und Hucke ja auch, aber es könnten noch viel mehr Leute sein, wenn das nicht so kompliziert wäre für bestimmte Sachen. Für wenn du ein bisschen, keine Ahnung hier, SP, wie heißt die, Open SPF und diese ganzen Protections und Zeug haben willst, dann wird es ja doch ein bisschen komplizierter. Und das könnte eigentlich viel leichter sein, finde ich.
Naja, die Frage ist ja auch immer, wie gut diese Einfachheit designt ist, schon in den Konzepten.
Ja, das ist alles so designt, dass es einfach alles können soll, man braucht nicht alles. Aber...
Ich brauche jetzt erst mal eine schnelle SSD in meinem Mac Pro. Das wird jetzt hier gleich mal bestellen.
Bestell mal.
Genau. Und meine Amazon Wunschliste ist leer.
Ja, ich hab sie dir leer gekauft.
Ich hab da nicht viel drauf und hab auch irgendwann aufgehört, da irgendwas draufzuschieben, weil, was soll ich mit dem ganzen Tand? Also wenn ich was brauche, dann kaufe ich mir das sowieso.
Sofort selbst.
Im Affekt. Und wenn ich da was drauf schiebe, mir das nicht selber kaufe, dann brauche ich das auch nicht. Das ist so nice to have Kram, der irgendwie die Wohnung noch voller macht, als sie ohnehin schon ist. Und dieser ganze Besitzwahnsinn ist irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, man hat viel zu viel von allem.
Ja, ich habe auch eine ganze Liste an Statistikbüchern, die einfach mal auf dieser Liste gelandet sind.
Irgendwann, wenn ich Zeit... Hab ich deine Liste?
Nein.
Gibt es mir deine Liste? Nein. Packen wir die hier...
Natürlich machen wir das.
Ich lasse mir nicht gerne was schenken. Weiß nicht. Geht nicht.
Das geht. Nein. So geht das nicht.
Es ist für mich schon schwierig, dass sie da manchmal Sachen nicht akzeptieren möchte.
Da reden wir gleich nochmal drüber. Genau. Naja, wir müssen alle nach Hause. So Tala, vielen Dank.
Gerne, gerne.
Für das Zurückkommen aus Japan.
Ja.
Jetzt bist du ja hier. Dann sehen wir uns noch häufiger. Letty, Dennis und ja, wir grüßen alle da draußen. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, fürs Zuschalten, fürs Einschalten, fürs Runterladen. Wir verabschieden uns und hören uns in zwei Wochen wieder.
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.
1971 lag das britische Empire in Trümmern. Auf den Straßen lömmelten und tümmelten sich Ausländer. Viele von ihnen waren Ungarn, nicht die Straßen die Ausländer. Na jedenfalls, viele dieser Ungarn gingen zu Tabakwarenhändlern, um Zigaretten zu erwärmen.
Ach, Herr, ich werde diese Scheiblatte nicht kaufen, sie ist zerkratzt.
Wie mein?
Ich werde diese Scheiblatte nicht kaufen, sie ist zerkratzt.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, wir verkaufen Tabakwaren.
Tabakwaren? Ich werde diese Tabakwaren nicht kaufen, sie ist zerkratzt.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, Tabakwaren und Zigaretten.
Mein Luftkissenfahrzeug ist voller Ahle. Wie meinen? Mein Luftkissenfahrzeug ist voller Ahle.
Ah, Streicher.
Ah, Streicher. Möchten Sie...
Möchten Sie...
Möchten Sie zu mir nach Hause kommen und Bumsi Bumsi?
Das macht Sechschillinge, bitte.
Wenn ich sagen würde, du hast einen schönen Körper, würdest du es gegen mich halten? Ich bin jetzt nicht mehr verseucht.